This is Jocko podcast number one 12 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I had a friend
and someday when I can I will tell you all about him,
but until then.
For now,
yeah,
I will say that I could not have asked for a better friend.
Did he have faults?
Sure.
Don't we all
now?
Most of his faults weren't really that big of a deal,
but they were raw,
raw because he admitted to them all openly and direct the and naively to be
honest,
you know,
sort of pointed in a heavy handed self critique.
He would bear his weaknesses to the world and to me and to himself
and he would speak to me as if I had no faults
can,
I would try to explain otherwise,
but he wouldn't listen.
He would only judge himself.
I'm too emotional.
He would say
not really.
I tell them,
I don't know how to talk to people.
Right?
Sure you do.
All right.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I make the same mistakes over and over and over again.
He would say we all do.
I would tell them
I was better than him at some things.
We both knew that
there were other things he was better at than me,
but he always downplayed those things
and we both knew that too
when we were overseas.
Okay.
In a bad place,
in a wretched place.
He never complained.
And I gave him every reason to.
I put him in the worst locations with the greatest possible chances for failure
and the highest probability for fire and fury and blood and death.
But despite the enemy and the heat and the living conditions and the fear and
the wounded men and the screams and the misery that was all around,
he did not complain.
Okay.
It seemed at times that God himself was trying to test the limits of my friend.
Yeah.
And it seemed like sooner or later,
yeah,
the bullets or the bombs would find him,
but through some in comprehensible miracle,
he survived through that deployment.
Now I make no claim whatsoever to understand why things in life unfold the way
they do.
Yeah.
In fact,
yeah.
I must say that many of the things I've seen in the world make no sense to me at
all.
Sometimes it's just utter confusion,
no rhyme,
no reason.
Some of the things that I've seen have left me downright disgusted.
Jay did
repulsed
sick into by mankind and the awful and reprehensible things we are capable of.
But there's another side to that.
There's another side and there are other people who do their best to redeem all
the evil our souls are capable of.
My friend was one of those people
after deploying with me and surviving that bloody and violent battlefield,
my friend,
like most of the guys in my old job,
he volunteered to deploy again.
Okay.
I fought and I told him prematurely and incorrectly that the enemy was done.
I told him that the war was all but over.
I told them,
just do the deployment and sit tight over there and play the game and in a few
months we'll be back and we can go surfing and we can play guitar and we can
tell stories and we can cook steaks and we can serve some more.
I told them we could carry on when he got home.
That was the plan.
It was a good point.
Okay.
But the enemy gets a vote
and there was intense violence during that deployment for him as well.
Okay.
It was similar to what we experienced together overseas and aggressive enemy.
Hell bent on killing Americans mixed in an urban environment with a terrified
local populace.
You told me that the enemy he was now facing wasn't as tactically skilled as the
enemy we had faced,
but he said that they were braver
and more determined.
Yeah.
That seemed to concern him a bit more.
You seem to feel the odds were that he would die.
Yeah.
He sent me his last will and testament.
He was not morose about it.
Just stating the facts.
It's bad over here,
the enemy's aggressive casualty rates are very high.
The enemy has new weapons that are extremely capable.
It didn't look good.
I waited.
I waited the long and completely powerless.
Wait,
one known mostly by mothers and fathers and wives and children that are old
enough to understand.
Okay.
But a weight also made
by the brothers at home.
Yeah,
but no,
the risk all too well.
Okay.
It was a long wait.
At my friend's memorial service,
his brother told a story.
My friend had talked to his brother on the phone while my friend was on
deployment
and my friend had explained to his brother in no uncertain terms,
the situation that my friend was in
the enemy,
he was extremely hostile.
The battlefield was chaotic,
the attacks were frequent and furious.
It was violence that my friend had not experienced before.
This was war unleashed and it seemed to be heading to an inescapable conclusion.
And my friend's brother senseless,
even through the phone,
even thousands of miles away as his brother,
he sensed the darkness and the overwhelming [inaudible] of the situation.
And you said to my friend,
okay,
do you need anything from me?
How can I help?
Okay.
Is there anything that I can do?
My friend was quiet for a moment
and then my friend made one simple request.
Yeah.
He said,
pray for my men.
No,
I want you to think about that.
Yeah.
I want you to think about that level of selflessness,
that level of faith and of commitment and of care for others.
That dedication
in the face of fear and violence and death to at that moment put others before
yourself
to do good.
To be heroic and strong and brave.
And yet at the same time to be humble,
you have to be willing to sacrifice everything for your friends.
Yeah,
that's a man.
And I couldn't have asked for a better friend.
The world can be a horrible place.
It's filled with violence and treachery and sometimes it seems that the legions
of demonic powers have the upper hand in the battle between good and evil and it
can seem that all might be lost.
Yeah.
And then
we remember
we see the light and for me the light comes from the example of others.
In this case,
another person,
another human being.
Okay.
My friend who despite all the powers of darkness stood up and rejected all that
wickedness and proved that there is hope
and there is a path to light.
Yeah.
And we can get on that path if we choose to do so.
Like my friend did.
And that's life
at least as far as I can unravel the mystery.
That's what I see.
We are here and the best thing we can do is stand against the darkness and tried
to spread light in the world.
But that can be a very hard thing to do
because life is not easy.
In fact,
it is said and there are very few that would deny that life itself is suffering,
but there is a way
and there is a path.
And today I have someone on the podcast for a second time that I think can help
guide us down that path
away from darkness
and toward the light.
Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
[inaudible] welcome back to the podcast for a second time.
Thanks jargon.
You were on podcast number 98 last time and if anyone wants to stop right now,
go and listen to 98 if you haven't listened to it yet and that's a good place to
start learning about you.
And then you could also just Google Jordan Peterson and go from there because
there's thousands.
You think there's thousands of hours of use of content of you on Youtube?
Yeah,
there's,
there's probably a horrible as it is to contemplate.
Yeah,
there probably is.
I mean,
I've contributed about,
okay,
500 hours probably in lectures and so on,
but people have been cutting it up and here's all the podcasts and youtube
videos that other people have made.
And I think I looked the other day because people keep chopping up the lectures
in the interviews and making little videos.
And my son and I tried to estimate it last week.
It looked like 4,000 people have made videos last week.
In one week.
Yeah.
It's really,
yeah,
it's crazy.
It's,
it's really,
yes.
Okay.
So you've got a new book out and the book is called 1212 rules for life,
an anecdote to chaos and w,
you know,
one of the key points in the book is life is suffering,
right.
And clearly,
um,
I think that isn't malevolence because the suffering is not enough.
You know,
we did a little bonus on top of that.
Yeah.
So we need to inflict it.
You know,
obviously my old line of work,
we got to see that and we got to see it all the time.
Two things.
Number one,
where does that come from?
And you don't need to spend a bunch of time on that because you've,
you've talked about that so much,
but more important to me,
what happens when people miss that point?
Well,
the suffering seems to be built in in some sense.
And,
and,
and it's a very difficult thing to understand fully because the fundamental
question is does being justified suffering?
It's something like that.
And there's this old idea,
I read this,
it was a Jewish idea.
It's kind of a riddle.
And so it's a riddle about the nature of God.
And so the riddle runs what does a being who's omniscient,
omnipotent and omnipresent.
So those are the three classical attributes of God lack think,
well that's
nothing.
Coffee Asley it's no limitation.
And so,
and so that was the explanation for why God created everything but more
particularly white God created man.
It's that there's something about limitation that adds to completeness maybe
because it provides something to struggle against.
It's something like that in the book and 12 rules for life.
I talk about what happens to happen to superman in the 1980s it's like superman
got so powerful that you could bounce hydrogen bombs off his chest,
you know,
and he could move planets.
It's like,
and then he got boring at the same time because what he,
what are you going to do to him?
Nothing is like he,
he can just solve every problem instantly.
Well,
there's no story there and you might say,
well,
who cares if there's a story and,
and that's a reasonable objection.
Maybe there should just be no story at all.
Right?
That's the Memphis to feely an objection to life.
There should be no story at all,
but maybe that's not the right answer.
Maybe it's better to have being,
even if it requires limitation,
even if the limitation necessitate suffering,
even if the limitation and the suffering necessitate evil and that that's a
separate issue,
perhaps there's a way of maneuvering through that,
a pathway that makes that all not only acceptable,
let's say at least acceptable.
That would be a good start,
but,
but fully justifiable.
Something that you would voluntarily accept if you had the opportunity,
niche.
Nature sort of cottoned on to that in some sense with his idea of the eternal
return.
He said you should try to live each moment of your life so that if you had to
live that moment recurring for eternity,
that you would find that desirable.
It's like that's a high standard man.
So,
but,
but there's a very interesting point there,
which is that maybe you can say that despite the suffering and malevolence this
is worth it and I,
people have experiences like that in their life,
you know,
um,
and you can have more experiences if you live your life.
I would say according,
if you're on the proper path than maybe your life can consist of almost nothing
but experiences like that.
Now,
you know,
I say that knowing full well that people get cut off at the knees and that life
can be very arbitrary and hard and that everyone is,
is prone to the negative consequences of deceit and betrayal.
All of those things.
I mean the book,
the book 12 rules for life in some senses a very dark book,
but it's not exactly because the darker the darkness,
the brighter the light appears.
It's something like that.
And you know,
you say,
well no,
life's not so bad.
You can be happy.
And I think no life really is bad.
It's really bad.
And no matter how bad you think it is,
it's actually worse than that.
You can't really get to the bottom of how terrible things can get.
You know,
people who have post traumatic stress disorder know that,
you know,
they've hit something so bad that they cannot live with it.
They have no idea how to live with it and it hurts them.
Not just psychologically,
but physiologically as well.
It's very difficult to recover.
So they have a sense of how bad it can be and then they can hardly live with it.
But I would say despite that,
and I would say also that this is the central idea in the in 12 rules for life,
is that despite that bottomless horror,
in some sense there is a way of being that's powerful enough to both transcend
and justify that in some sense.
And that has to do with with,
with the decision to act as if it would be better if things were better.
That's the first thing.
And you think,
well that's easy.
I'd like things to be better.
It's no,
no,
wait a second.
There's hatred in your heart and there's resentment in your soul and there's
bitterness at your position in the world and there's the sense that you're a
victim and there's the anger that goes along with that and that desire to hurt.
Like you have all of that and maybe you have it in spades.
Maybe it's mostly what you are.
And because of that,
you do not want things to be better.
You want to spread some misery out of spite.
And that's what chapter six is about,
right?
And put your house in perfect order before you criticize the world.
It's about people like the Columbine high school shooters and exactly what they
were motivated by because I understand what they were motivated by.
And so to wish that things were better means that you have to make a real
decision.
That despite all the flaws of existence,
the suffering and the malevolence,
that it's best not to become embittered by that and to work for the betterment
of everyone.
You for sure your family,
for sure your community,
but perhaps even your enemies,
you know,
if you have any sense you wish your enemies well,
it doesn't mean you wish the victory.
It doesn't mean you don't think they're wrong,
none of that.
It means that it would be better if the world was set up so that they didn't
have to suffer miserably and futilely and Evilee as well.
That would be better.
And so then you can aim at that now.
And the best way to aim it out as well,
first of all day Matt,
it to actually sort yourself out and think,
okay,
well if I could have things the way I wanted them to be,
that's what I would want.
Right?
And that takes a lot of psychological organization before you can state that
without,
what would you say without holding anything back?
You know,
because there's that part of you,
that bitter part,
that wants vengeance and wants and wants to,
to wreak havoc that's there.
It's hard to constrain that.
And then while the other part along with this as well as aiming at the highest
good that's attainable,
let's say,
is to also decide that you're going to speak the truth in that endeavor and to
risk that.
You know,
and there's that and because I think those are the things that that help you
aren't yourself properly.
That's the message on the sermon on the mount,
by the way,
which is aim at the highest good that you can conceive of and act and tell the
truth in that pursuit.
Right?
The other element there is to focus on the day.
Once you've,
once you've aligned yourself with the heavenly star,
right?
Aim High and then focus on the day.
That's very good advice because it also imbues everything you do in your daily
life with significance.
It's the,
why am I doing this?
To avoid.
Hell,
that's a good one.
Let's start with that.
It's like to avoid hell,
and if you have any imagination at all,
if you lived in the world at all,
if you're not naive,
you know what that means.
It's not just the hell that you encounter.
It's the hell that you foolishly produce around yourself and are then
responsible for.
That's a perfectly good sort of hell.
So you want to avoid that for sure.
And maybe you want to dare risking making things better.
It's like that'll imbue your life with significance and that significance.
You know,
one of the things I've discovered,
learned,
I would say over the last 25 years,
is that there's always been a mythological idea or an ID and literature and
philosophy that there was a shining path.
You know,
that you could walk down and modern,
cynical people believe that that sort of meaning the meaning that would be
obtained by walking on that path is somehow illusory or arbitrary.
And I don't think there's any evidence whatsoever that that's true.
I think that sense of meaningful engagement,
that
what is revealed to you when you're in the right place at the right time,
doing the right thing.
That sense of deep engagement,
that loss of self consciousness,
that feeling that things are worthwhile,
that deep seated feeling,
that things are worthwhile.
That's the most real thing I think.
I think the neuro biological evidence suggests that.
I really do believe that.
And so we're in a fortunate time in some sense because we can look at those old
metaphorical ideas of the,
of the Shining Path,
let's say the,
the,
the golden path forward.
And we can say,
yeah,
that's actually real.
It's real.
And that something.
And then that's,
so what's this,
what's so cool about that in my estimation is that,
and this is why 12 rules for life is actually an optimistic book is like the
darkness is real,
but the light is stronger.
It's like,
wow,
could that be true?
Could that possibly be true?
I think it's true.
So that's a good thing to know,
man,
that that might be true.
And,
and you know,
the w when I was talking about my friend in the beginning of this podcast,
that's,
that's why I was talking about it because it was a guy who had every reason to
be,
to be negative and to be dark and to look at the world and just say,
this is hell and it's not worth it.
But instead what he really did was want to take care of his,
of his friends.
I talk about a woman in my book is someone I met as a client when I was just
beginning my psychotherapeutic practice and she just blew me away.
I've never forgotten her.
So she was,
she had a horrible life.
She was unattractive,
uneducated,
um,
no career unemployed,
so shy,
you can't even imagine it.
Like you've met someone shy and anxious.
It's like they weren't in the same universe is this woman.
She was so shy that she couldn't walk up to people without looking at the
ground,
hunching over and shielding her eyes.
So that's how she approached people on the street.
And,
and she,
she,
she looked like a homeless person as well.
And so,
um,
and she came to the behavior therapy unit that I was working at and,
hypothetically for treatment.
And so what,
what we started doing was seeing if we could get her to stand up a bit and look
people in the eye more normally so that people wouldn't respond to her as if she
was so peculiar,
you know.
So we were trying to just to change your behavior,
but I started talking to her and,
well she told me a little bit about her life.
It's like she lived at editor,
she lived where she lived.
Her mother was,
I think she lived with her aunt who was like a violent schizophrenia alcoholic
who had religious delusions and constantly accused her of being possessed by the
devil.
And she had a really violent and abusive alcoholic boyfriend who used to
mistreat this woman.
So that was like home life.
It's like,
yeah.
And she had been an inpatient in this hospital,
the Douglas Hospital.
And that was in the 1980s.
And the Douglas Hospital was a huge hospital,
both size of a university campus and it had had a lot of inpatients.
But they were all let out on the streets when medication became widely available
and when deinstitutionalization was the norm.
But there was a subset of them who couldn't be d institutionalized.
And these were people that you can hardly imagine.
So I used to go in the underground corridors in the Douglas Hospital because
it's very cold in Montreal.
So there underground corridors collecting the buildings and down
there there would be vending machines in places for people to sit.
And it was like walking through Dante's inferno cause these were people who were
so damaged.
You know,
they'd been in a psychiatric institution for maybe two or three decades.
They could not be released no matter what,
even though that's what the hospital was trying to do.
And so it was like Diane Arbus used to go across the United States and
photograph strange people and she has a whole collection of her photographs.
They're quite arresting and shocking.
And it was like walking through Diane Arbus is universe,
you know?
And so those were the inpatients and she had been an inpatient from time to
time,
but was well enough.
So she could also go out and it turned out she didn't actually want treatment.
She had this dog,
she used to take it for walks.
And so that was her source of enjoyment.
Right.
And she thought,
I really liked this dog and I really like taking him for walks and maybe I could
go to the Douglas Hospital and find one of these inpatients and take them out
for a walk.
Maybe that would be a good thing for him.
And so the reason she had come to the behavior therapy clinic wasn't to treat
all of her problems.
And this woman had problems.
Man,
everything about her life was a problem in,
in ways that like a normal person just cannot begin to understand,
you know,
unless they're in one of those situations in their life where everything is
collapsing around them.
And what she did,
what she decided was,
well there's someone worse off than me than me that I could help.
It's like she just absolutely blew me away.
You know,
this poor woman,
she had nothing going for her while it gets,
she did day cause she had this nobility of spirit that was absolutely
indomitable.
It just,
I never forgot that.
It just blew me away.
Lead her into her situation in a way of she's so noble and she wants to help
her,
her aunt,
that's all crazy and no one wants to help prop up her boyfriend that's violent
and no,
I don't think so.
I don't think she wanted any of that.
She was just one of these people.
It's like,
you know,
you can put someone in a situation that's so dire that,
that there's virtually no escape from it.
Like I've seen people in my clinical practice for whom things around things
around them have collapsed so badly that there's just no fixing it.
There's you fixed one thing and two other things break and then you fix those
and three other things break.
There's just no bottom.
And those are often families that have had multigenerational problems.
Deeply rooted.
The whole community is pathologized,
the entire family structure is demolished.
They're there.
People don't have any marketable skills and they haven't for generations.
The whole situation is complicated by drug and alcohol abuse and heavily
biologically influenced insanity of one form or another.
Usually conjoined with relatively low cognitive ability.
It's just,
it's just hell no matter which way you turn.
And I didn't see her as a contributor to that.
I mean,
I'm sure she made her mistakes like everyone else,
but she was,
she certainly wasn't playing martyr or victim.
She,
she didn't come in to the,
to the clinic to complain to with,
but just like she was just telling me these were the,
the situation that she lived in,
she wasn't,
that isn't what she was,
therefore,
it's just that we thought she had come for treatment.
So we were doing the background analysis,
you know,
an intake interview and found out all these things.
It's like any one of those problems is enough to bring most people's lives to a
shuddering halt.
And yet that was her vision.
So the reason she had come to the hospital and she didn't just come to the
behavior therapy clinic,
she had gone around pestering administrators in the hospital to let her take the
longterm inmates out for a walk.
Now they wouldn't do it for,
you know,
for all sorts of reasons.
But that didn't stop her from thinking it was a good idea and it actually was a
good idea.
This was a practical idea.
Like she could have taken people out on the grounds because the grounds were
huge and walk them with the dog and it would've been fine for such a thing as
pet therapy in 1985 yeah,
well right,
exactly.
Exactly.
But she had enough wherewithal to notice that well that she liked the dog and
the dog like turn out.
That was a good thing.
Right?
The little bit of love in the world there and that there was nothing wrong with
taking the dog for a walk and that was kind of harmless.
And why not have someone along,
it's made her feel good.
She thought,
well maybe it'll make the yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So like beat,
you just got to shake your head.
Well,
that's when I really learned to begin with deeply that there's no correlation
between intelligence and wisdom and then that's actually the case.
Technically like if you're smart,
you can just be like,
you can be,
you can be smart and good,
but you could be smart,
bad.
It's just as well.
We used to say,
okay,
so we'd get these guys coming in the seal teams.
That wouldn't be for a while we were recruiting just the,
for the officer candidates,
we were creating these guys that were,
you know,
they went to Ivy League schools and they were off the charts and 1600 on their
sats and then they were the captain of this.
They were just these really high achievers and we found that not all of them,
but certainly some of them couldn't really function in the,
as a,
as a leader in the job because they just didn't have the,
I guess the wisdom to,
to pull it off,
but they couldn't make the personal connections.
They couldn't develop the relation.
The leadership's a complicated thing and it doesn't boil down just to
intelligence.
Yeah.
And I don't want to make it sound like none of them work aside from work.
Obviously outstanding,
incredible leaders.
But there were some of them that would be the same kind of recruit,
but they just were missing whatever piece of that was.
Well,
intelligence and character are definitely not the same thing.
They're not the same thing.
I mean,
all things considered,
if you're going to pick one of two leaders,
if I would pick the smarter leader over the Duller leader,
if all other things were equal,
you know,
because well,
because someone who's more intelligent can strategize more rapidly and can
handle more variables,
right.
And perhaps can even handle while can have handle a more rapid rate of
transformation as well.
And sometimes that's actually crucial,
but character and intelligence are,
are,
they're clearly not the same thing.
And characters actually,
well,
I don't think anything,
Trump's character,
that's,
that character is everything.
So you know,
it's interesting that you,
with this,
this woman that you talked about in the beginning,
you talk about how she's,
you know,
she's crouched down and she's looking down at the ground and all that.
So it's interesting in your roles obviously the,
the first,
the first rule is to stand up straight with your shoulders back.
Right?
Well when you get,
for lack of a better word,
indoctrinated,
in fact there is no better word when you get indoctrinated into the military,
that's exactly what's happening.
And guess what?
You get taught.
One of the first things that you get taught is how to stand,
how to stand properly.
And you know what they tell you?
Chin up,
chest out,
shoulders back.
They make you stand like that.
There's no coincidence to that is there?
You could say it's a dominant stance but I that's not the right way of thinking
about it.
Although it is a dominant stance,
the reason to adopt it is not because it's a dominant stance,
it's a competent stance and competence tends to make you dominant at least in in
hierarchies that are functioning property cause you want,
there are hierarchies,
which is what I outline in chapter one.
I say the hierarchies are old.
They're not socio cultural constructions.
They're not a secondary consequence of capitalism in the free mark.
All of that is absolute nonsense.
It couldn't be more wrong.
And as an indication of that,
I point out that lobsters whom we diverged from on the evolutionary front a
third of a billion years ago,
have hierarchies,
right?
And that the neurochemical systems,
the neural neurological systems that lobsters have runoff that mediate their
hierarchical status run on the same chemical that the neurological systems that
we use to mediate hierarchy run on.
So that's just absolutely mind boggling.
But lobster,
like a victorious lobster stretches out and adopt some more dominant poets
because his serotonin levels go up as he becomes more and more victorious and
that governs posture while and so to stand up straight with your shoulders back
is to open yourself up to the world.
You're not in a diff,
you're not in a defensive crouch of a prey animal,
technically speak it.
And that is the circuitry that's governing posture.
It's prey versus Predator or something like that.
And,
and it just stand up like that is to expose your yourself to the world,
but in a bring it on sort of manner.
Not,
not precisely combative,
but let's say courageous and your posture announces that and it doesn't just
announce that to other people.
It announces that to yourself and it can start.
It can be one of those things that can start a virtuous cycle occurring,
which is partly why it's taught in the military.
You get these guys that come in,
they're all slumped over,
they don't know how to stand up.
They're looking at their feet,
their necks are band.
Like,
even if they're good looking men,
they don't look good because they're all crunched over.
You see people like this on the street all the time.
They can be perfectly attractive except they're completely huddled in,
you know,
and they need to stand up and stretch themselves out and then they can breathe
too.
And that's a competent stance.
And one of the things that the critics of the modern West don't understand about
hierarchies is that first of all,
they're everywhere.
They're,
they're inevitable.
If you're going to have a distinction of value between things,
you have a hierarchy.
And if you,
you don't want to get rid of the distinction of values between things because
then you don't have anything to do.
That's foolish.
You can't live that way.
So I say,
well,
the hierarchies are based on power.
It's like,
no,
they're not.
They're based on competence.
And there isn't anything more powerful than competence.
But power isn't tyranny.
It's not brutality.
It's not threat.
It might be the hint of all those things,
you know,
because I don't think you can be fully competent without being able to hint at
those things.
But hierarchies in the West are fundamentally based on competence.
That doesn't mean they're not flawed because we missed the mark lots.
And there's lots of reasons why perfectly competent people don't attain the
position that they deserve and that they should have for their benefit and
everyone else's,
that the hierarchy's are tainted by corruption.
But fundamentally they're fundamentally,
they're based on competence.
So
and,
and that's so,
so with that,
this first rule that you put into that book,
and you're saying that's a cycle that can go backwards so you don't have to have
like the serotonin first and then you stand up.
If you stand up straight,
you will somehow increase your serotonin over.
Definitely.
You can actually see,
you see,
you say you could inject lobsters with Serotonin and they start to stand
straighter.
Yeah,
you can basically
antidepressants.
So like if a lobster gets defeated in a fight,
then he's statistically more likely to lose the next fight than you would guess
from a telly of his previous victories.
So that's the first thing.
If you lose,
you increase your risk of further loss.
But if you,
when you increase your risk of future gains,
that's,
that's a very important principle.
It's a crucially important principle.
It governs life.
But yeah,
if you take a lobster and he gets all defeated and he's off pouting and won't
fight anymore because he's,
you know,
having a bad day and you inject him with Serotonin,
essentially give him antidepressants,
it's the same thing.
Then he'll straighten up and you'd go out and have another scrap.
And it's like,
and I read that,
oh,
I don't know.
It's probably at least 10 years ago when I was reading about,
well,
the neurophysiology of these neurochemical systems.
That's why I got onto it.
It just was another thing that just blew me away.
I thought,
really,
you're kidding.
That circuit is that old.
It's like,
it's that old Siri,
you know,
that's way before there were trees.
That's how long ago that is.
And so hierarchy is a patriarchal construction.
How bout no,
that's wrong and seriously wrong.
I had up,
I was talking to one of my friends either night.
Uh,
his name is Joe.
He's got a kid that's wrestling.
His kid is six years old,
I think dom.
And he says,
you know,
he's getting put into the higher category is kind of getting these bought whip
now.
And I'm really not sure.
What do you think?
And I said,
well,
you want him to win because when he wins,
it's fun and we have more fun.
So now I have actual more evidence that you should get your kids in a position
again.
I think your kid should get beat sometimes.
Yeah.
But they should certainly not get beat down all the time.
I did that to my kids when my kids first started Jujitsu,
I put them,
oh,
you're good,
you're gonna compete because I'm just telling you to.
Yeah.
And then I'm gonna put you in a higher weight class with older kids because
that's going to make you tougher.
That was my,
you know,
stupid thinking.
And now with my youngest daughter,
I'm like,
no,
no.
You go on and you have fun and you go out and you compete against people that
are somewhat equal to you.
Maybe a little bit below you,
maybe a little higher,
but depending on your mood times.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Well that's,
I think we could,
we could think about that also in terms of,
of the conversation about meaning that we started to have.
It's like if you win all the time,
that's meaningless.
Because when you think why?
Because you want to win.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
So why would winning all the time become meaningless?
It's because your theory of winning isn't sophisticated
enough because here's how you win.
You play the game to win,
but while you're playing,
you play in a way so that you get better at the game,
right?
Because you're going to play a bunch of games.
Well,
it's even more than that.
You play the game to win,
but you play it so that you get better at the game.
Okay,
fine.
That makes sense.
So you want to push yourself,
right?
Because that's how you get better.
And so you need competition to push yourself.
So you need to have the risk of loss.
Cause otherwise you won't do it.
But here's an even better way of thinking about it.
You play the game so that you don't only get better at that game,
but you get better at the entire set of possible games.
And that's what you do when you're a good sport.
It's like,
well,
so how do you do that?
Well,
partly you,
you find the proper level of competition,
right?
So you want to be pushed
so that you will make the effort necessary to remove what's useless about
yourself and to help foster the growth of what's useful.
And if you do that,
then you get the,
the joy of participating in the game towards victory.
But the extra joy of building yourself more and more strongly at the same time.
And so when you tell your kid,
doesn't matter whether you win or lose,
it's how you play the game.
Your kid says,
what do you mean by that?
And you say,
I don't know.
I don't know what I mean by that.
Cause the kid says I'm supposed to win our die.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
so why does it matter how I play the game?
It's like,
well then you're stumped.
Even though you're right,
you just don't know why.
But the reason is is you want to want to
tell you,
here's the reason.
It's like we can make this very simple,
life is not a game.
It's a series of games.
It's actually a series of diverse games.
Okay,
so who's the winner of this series of diverse games?
Because that's the real question,
right?
Not who wins a game.
It's like whatever you win a game,
it's like if I hold a gun to your head and we're playing chess,
I can say lose.
I win.
It's like,
well
that's not helpful obviously.
So you want to teach your kid,
you want to help your kid learn to be the winner of the set of diverse games.
Okay,
so what does that winner look like?
Well,
here's the first clue.
That's the person who keeps getting invited to play.
You know?
So because you win,
if people invite you to play all the time,
you have opportunities coming to you just nonstop.
And maybe like,
let's say you have 50 opportunities and each of them are potentially 50% for you
and 50% for the other person.
You think,
well that's pretty good deal.
And then you think,
well,
wait a minute,
let's flip this around.
So it's like 60% for the other person and 40% for me,
I'm going to be like,
I'm going to go,
I'm going to overboard.
And the generosity,
you think,
well then what happens?
Well then instead of having 20 opportunities at every moment,
you have like 50 opportunities at every moment.
And that's so that's what you want for your kids as you want all the invisible
doors around them to open.
And you do that by sand play notably,
right?
Pay attention to your teammates passed the damn puck so they get a chance,
Even if you're the best player on the team,
help the people on your team developed.
Don't grandstand,
right.
Um,
don't,
if you have the opportunity to beat your opponent 20 to one you know,
and goals,
it doesn't happen very often,
but it can,
especially when kids are playing,
it's like,
well,
maybe after you're up seven to one it's like
back off a bit.
You don't have to humiliate your opponents.
It's because it's,
it's,
what would you say?
It's a contemptible behavior on your part.
And so you know that because you go and watch a hockey game or something like
that and you watch a kid that really knows how to play.
It's like they're playing like mad to when they're pushing themselves to be
better,
but they're paying attention to their damn teammates and there they respect
their opponents and you think,
well that's,
that's a hell of a kid there.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly right that that kid's going somewhere to do.
Kids ever show they get so committed,
let's say hockey,
right?
You get a kid that's just so committed to winning and hockey that he's going to
lose it other games.
While that's,
that's not an easy life.
Right.
That that's another,
well that's another problem is like you could be overboard.
Yeah.
Well,
well the other thing too is that with sports,
like you could say,
well most kids aren't going to be NHL level hockey players.
Like that's impossible.
Like maybe you should aim for that.
I would say probably not because it's so damn unlikely,
but whatever.
Some kids are going to manage that and more power to them say,
well,
what are the sports for,
for the rest of the kids?
And the answer to that is,
well obviously there's the physical discipline and,
and the health that goes along with that and the ability to engage in and
tolerate competition and learn how to be a gracious winner and a gracious loser.
But a lot of it is care that all that's part of character building.
Well that's what you want is you say,
well,
why build your character?
It's like,
well how,
how bout that's your set of toolkits for,
that's your set of tools for dealing with catastrophe.
How about that for a reason?
Right.
So one of the things I've,
I've suggested to my viewers,
this is the men in particular,
but not just the men.
Um,
you should be the most reliable person at your father's funeral.
That's a good goal,
man.
That's a good goal because everyone's broken in a situation like that and you
adding to that brokenness and misery.
I mean,
you're going to be grieving like no doubt about it and no kidding.
But there is a time to step forward with some character,
you know?
And it's the same thing.
You're going to be at someone's deathbed.
You going to be quibbling with your siblings while you're doing that,
while your parents dying.
It's like it's bad enough that they're dying.
That's tragedy,
right?
But you'd can turn that into hell,
no problem.
He just get a bunch of people with no character around a deathbed.
And it's like,
well,
it's bad enough,
but that turns it into something like hell.
And that happens in people's lives all the time.
It's like character is everything.
So,
and that's why the wise people of our past tradition insisted upon that.
He say,
well,
don't lie.
Well why not?
Well destroys your character.
Well,
so what?
Well then you turn suffering into hell.
Is that what you want?
Maybe,
you know,
cause people will want that.
But I would say walk away from people like that.
Right?
That's not,
unless that's what you want then.
Yeah.
And you've got a lot of,
uh,
I mean it's,
it's interesting as I'm,
since I just got done reading the book,
you don't,
I can hear you just hitting the wave tops of all the different rules and they're
all interconnected about,
don't,
you know,
don't lie or,
or,
or tell the truth or at least don't lie.
And then,
you know,
hang on.
What's the,
what's the chapter about hanging around with people that want to see you do
well,
yeah,
yeah.
Make friends with people who want the best for you.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
and it's a really,
it's a real technical idea.
So Carl Rogers,
who's a psychotherapist,
great psychotherapist,
I'd very much recommend his books to people,
especially if they want to learn to listen,
because he was really good at teaching people how to listen.
He had this idea that what he would manifest towards his clients in therapy was
unconditional positive regard.
And I've always had trouble with that because,
well,
because you don't treat your children,
for example,
with unconditional positive.
Yeah.
As you're saying.
That's a good idea.
It's
tricky.
Well,
what do you,
he didn't articulate it.
I think as well as he might have,
what you want to do is for your child is that you want the best for the best in
them.
That's what you want and that's what you want from people that you surround
yourself with.
Now they'll hold you to a high standard if that's the case,
right?
Because whenever you degenerate in any of the multiple ways that you're likely
be degenerate,
they're going to like whack you on the back of the head and say,
you know,
clue the hail in.
You know,
you're,
you're demeaning yourself,
you're less than you could be.
And there's real judgment and it's harsh,
you know?
But with friends it's the same thing.
You want friends,
they're not friends.
If they're not these people,
you want friends.
When something good happens to you there,
that's good for you,
right?
They're happy about that.
They're not like all bitter and resentful underground and like saying horrible
things behind your back and telling you how they did something that was better
and trying to drag you down.
It's like,
that's not helpful.
And then when something bad happens to you and you go to them and you say,
look,
this terrible thing happened to me.
First of all,
they don't try to top it with some like horrible thing that happened to them
because they don't have the patience to listen.
And second,
they're not secretly gloating about the fact that catastrophe finally be fail
you.
It's like they're actually hurt by it and that chapter is an injunction is like
take a look at the people that are around you and if they're not on this side of
what's good for you,
then walk away because well first of all,
that's best for them too.
If you put up with that,
all you're doing is enabling it.
It's like,
well,
it's okay that you mistreat me in a way that's harmful to me and everyone else.
It's like,
actually no,
that is not okay.
It's not an,
it's not the least bit.
Okay.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't try to help someone when they're down.
That's a whole different issue.
What if it's your family,
so you know how you say like walk away,
right?
Yep.
Do you still walk away from your family or do you can do if it's necessary?
There's lots of different ways of walking away.
They'll create while there's that,
for sure there's that.
I mean you,
you sometimes someone's on an incredible path,
like there's just nothing you can do.
You know,
maybe they're aiming down their aim,
aiming down hard and they're bitter and everything they do is to produce misery
virtually everything.
And you have to detach yourself from that.
It's like,
I always think about it from the perspective of a lifeguard.
So if you're training to be a lifeguard,
one of the things that you're trained to do is to approach someone who's
drowning and panicking.
And the way you approach them is you put your foot out between you and them and
you push forward with your hands,
with your foot out.
And you basically tell them if they're flailing about,
you say,
look,
I'm here to help,
but you have to calm down.
And then if they claim to you like in panic,
you push them away,
you think,
well that's pretty damn cruel.
Because what if they drown?
It's like,
yeah,
what if you both drowned?
That's like not helpful.
You're,
you're there to rescue them.
They take you down,
you're both dead.
It's like fail,
right?
So you say,
look,
quit panicking.
I'll help you out,
but I'm not drowning along with you.
It's like,
well,
it's the same with someone in your family.
It's like if they're on a downward path and you've done your best,
you know you've,
you've made your efforts,
you've,
and they're not paying attention.
They're not changing.
They say,
yeah,
we'll,
I'll quit doing this.
Quit doing this.
They tell you the same story over and over and over.
It's a downhill path.
You don't trust it at some point.
First of all,
you stop offering your words.
That's do not cast pearls before swine.
A very,
very harsh statement,
right?
But what it means is if someone,
if you're offering words of wisdom to someone in the genuine attempt help and
they treat that with contempt,
then shut up because you're demeaning your words by throwing them away.
You think,
well,
how do you help someone who's aiming down?
Well,
sometimes you help them by walking away and saying,
look,
you're aiming down so hard that I am despite the fact you're my brother,
man.
It's like,
you know,
this is killing me.
You're aiming down so hard.
I'm not coming along with you.
And the reason I'm not is to tell you in no uncertain terms that what you're
doing is so terrible that I will even violate our kinship to oppose it.
And maybe it'll take them 10 years to wake up to that,
you know?
And so that can be the case because you know,
people often have to be hit so many times before they'll learn.
You see that,
especially if someone's addicted or,
or,
or otherwise pursuing a pathway that's like seriously downhill.
So Yep.
Harsh you port,
you cover that pretty well in that chapter where you're saying there's a certain
point where you just got to say,
we're done.
Yeah,
We're done.
Well,
it's like,
why should I think that you're actually trying to change?
Maybe you're just telling me is you're,
you tell me the story that you use to justify your own idiocy to yourself and
then you tell it to me and you demand that because I'm compassionate,
I accepted,
and therefore validate your excuse.
It's like,
well,
that Ha,
like it's really hard not to get tangled up in that.
Right?
Because if someone who's really in rough shape is telling you about why they're
suffering,
first of all,
they're probably about half right in their story.
But some of its justification and excuse and blaming and all of that failure to
take responsibility,
it's really hard to stand up and say,
no,
I don't buy that.
No,
you're wrong about that.
You have to be a brutal bastard in order to do that.
But hey,
sometimes like surgery is brutal.
It's brutal,
but
a to cut you open and we're going to rip out part of your,
yeah,
right,
right.
Exactly right.
Precisely.
And so,
so this chapter about,
you know,
only making friends with people who want the best for you.
That's a brutal chapter.
No,
but it's right.
Unfortunately,
going to your book a little bit,
I'm going to,
I'm going to pick up,
going back to that first thought.
Standing up means voluntarily excepting the burden of being your nervous system
responds in an entirely different manner.
When you face the demands of life voluntarily,
you respond to a challenge.
Instead of bracing for a catastrophe,
you see the gold,
the dragon hoards instead of shrinking and terror from the all too real fact of
the dragon,
you step forward to take your place in the dominance hierarchy and occupy your
territory.
Manifesting your willingness to defend,
expand,
and transform.
To stand up straight with your shoulders back is to accept the terrible
responsibility of life with eyes wide open.
Right?
The reason I pulled that one out in particular is the feeling that you have as a
soldier or as a,
as a military person,
a feeling that you have going on and off offensive operation where let's say
you're a bad guy and I'm gonna come and get you at night.
Well first of all,
you don't know and I'm sneaking up on you and I have all this power,
right?
I feel good about it.
I'm going to get you the opposite of that is when I'm doing a convoy or I'm
going on a patrol,
we're now the bad guys are out there.
They're waiting to attack me.
And that is a defensive posture and your attitude about that type of thing is
bad.
Now we were train our guys that we,
we made a specific point with my guys.
I would say,
look,
when you're on patrol,
we're on the offense.
We are scanning,
we are looking to get the,
to get us to be standing up straight and to get the mentality of we want to do
this and we're moving towards the target as opposed to we're being chased.
That's a big deal.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's what would you say?
That's an extreme example of what's necessary under normal conditions in life.
So one of the things that happens if you're treating someone who has a phobia,
say like agoraphobic.
So they become afraid of virtually everything.
Um,
maybe they're afraid of an elevator.
It's one of many fears.
And so you think,
well,
and they're afraid of an elevator because they've actually gone in elevators and
have panic attack.
So it's weird because what you do to cure them is to get them to go in elevators
and you think,
well wait a second.
That's actually what caused the problem.
So how can getting them to do that again,
make it better.
And now answer is because they've gone in elevators their whole life,
right?
And yet they still become terrified.
So how can getting them to go in an elevator cure them for a long time?
People thought,
well,
you get them to relax while they were in the elevator.
And the pairing of the relaxation with being in the elevator taught them to not
be afraid.
That was the first theory.
But then people learned,
didn't know you could just get them to go in the elevator without having them
relax.
And it also worked.
And eventually psychologist sorted this out and what they figured out was that
voluntarily encountering something you're afraid of is not the same thing as
running from it.
Like it's seriously not the same thing.
So you say to the person,
okay,
you're afraid of the elevator,
let's can you go look at an elevator?
And they usually say yes and maybe they're so terrified because they're so far
gone in their illness that they can't say,
well how about we'll look at a bunch of pictures of elevators since like
virtually everyone can do that.
So I'd say,
let's look at pictures of elevators till your board.
That actually doesn't take very long because it's actually quite boring.
So then the next thing would be,
well,
let's go.
You have to have the person trust you.
And so the rule is,
look,
we're going to do some things that are going to push you like competition,
but you can stop whenever you want and we're not going to push you any farther
than is good for you and I'll stop anytime you want.
I often practice with my clients,
like I taught one client a while back to be afraid of needles
and he was afraid of needles.
And I'll tell you what that meant.
He had dental surgery with no anesthesia.
Oh,
okay.
So that gives you some level of what it's like to be afraid.
It's like all do the dental surgery,
but you're not putting that needle in there.
It's really,
it's like I'm no needles so,
so I taught them how to not be afraid of of needles,
you know,
and it,
it didn't take very long.
But the first thing I did,
I told him I was going to bring a needle into the office.
That was all I told him.
The first week is next week I'm going to bring a needle in here and I'm going to
keep it sheets and it's going to be sitting on a shelf and that's where I'm
going to put it.
And when you come in here,
you can look at it and if you want me to put it away,
then I'll put it away.
It's under your control.
And then so he was okay with that.
So he came in,
there's the needless to do you want to look at it and said,
no,
he's but Kenyon.
It's like all look at it.
So he looked at it and then it said,
look like I'm going to pick up the needle and now what you're going to do is
you're going to tell me to put it down and I'm going to put it down.
So I picked it up and he got nervous,
like right away,
and he said,
well,
you put that down.
I put it down right away.
I said,
we do that 10 times so that the bottom part of your nervous system actually
knows that that's what's going to happen.
Said now and then the next thing we'll do is we're going to practice you saying
you've had enough and leaving the office.
So I pick up the needle and he'd say,
okay,
so now you say you've had enough,
I'm leaving.
And so he said that,
and then I'd let them leave.
We did that like 10 times so that he knew that he could just say he'd had enough
and leave.
So that mean he didn't have to be a prey animal.
Right?
So we're getting them out of that mode and it didn't take very long until,
well then I could bring the needle close to them and they said,
make sure you watch it.
You can't pretend it's not there.
Right.
I'll bring it close to them and touch and touch them with the sheath needle.
So we did that a bunch and then finally I unchaste it and I'd bring it close and
he tolerate that or stop me.
And then I touched him with that.
And then the last part of it was that,
um,
I put it under a piece of paper so he couldn't see it.
And then I'd bring it close to him.
Right.
Cause that was,
that was the unknown.
Right?
You don't know what the hell is going on underneath the piece of paper.
But he got to the point where he could go and have a needle.
I took on about,
it was very brave of him to do this because,
well,
what had happened,
he got,
what had happened to him is he had a very bad experience with the childhood
dentist.
Held him down.
Oh yeah.
Held him.
Six people held them down to give him a needle.
It's like it wasn't so good.
It had some longterm consequences.
But see what happens.
So when you,
when you do that with people,
you don't teach them to be less afraid.
You teach them to be braver.
That's different.
And so like I had a client once the doors open on the elevator and she looked
and she said,
that's death.
Like that's a tube.
And I thought,
wow,
that's an amazing response.
And her idea what,
she'd go in there,
her heart rate would accelerate,
she'd have a heart attack and she die.
So as far as she was concerned,
walking in,
there was death.
Right.
Okay.
So for me it was an elevator,
but for her it was death.
It's like,
okay,
well what do you do about your fear of death?
Well,
we're not getting rid of that.
It's like,
you know,
and you could die in the elevator.
You actually could,
probably,
you won't.
But people do die in elevators.
And her idea was that,
well,
if anyone has ever died in an elevator in the history of mankind,
that's a good reason for me not to be in the elevator.
It's like,
fair enough.
You know?
And then why aren't you terrified out of your skull all the time?
Because while you're wandering around,
you might have a heart attack like that.
We'll probably in fact happened to you at some point.
So why aren't you terrified at that at every moment?
Well,
that's the mystery.
so you treat people and,
and you see with that client,
what I eventually did with hers,
we went and watched an embalming.
She was terrified of death.
Like seriously?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
No kidding.
But you know,
so you get,
you don't get less afraid.
You get braver.
That's better because there's plenty of things to be afraid of,
but you can get braver.
So that's something people manage this on their own ever.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
People manage it on their own.
They'd manage it on their own all the time.
Like,
you know,
let's say you're in a rowdy,
horrible job and you're being oppressed by your boss and one day you think I've
had enough,
and you go write your resume.
It's like,
there you go.
That's what you're doing.
And it's like,
you know,
you're,
because you think,
well,
I've got the devil I know.
And,
and then there's devil I don't know.
And that's relevant when you're,
when you're trying to switch careers cannot find another job.
Will anyone hire me?
How long would this take?
Two.
I have to get educated again.
I have to put my resume together.
That's a real pain because there's holes in it and I don't know how to present
myself.
Then I have to go to interviews and it's like,
oh my God,
that's,
you know,
that's a lot of trouble.
Well then you think,
no,
I'm going to start that.
I'm going to rewrite my resume.
It's like,
well then you get right and just you're moving forward in your life.
You're not taken being tyrannized by your son of a bitch of a boss and you're
out to do something about it.
You know?
And people can get really good at that.
So one of the things you do is a psychotherapist.
You do assertiveness training.
It's like,
so people come and they say,
help help.
I'm being oppressed in the famous Monty python in the famous Monty python
manner.
And you say,
okay,
look,
well first of all,
you're probably whining a lot.
So let's figure that out.
So you quit whining and then let's figure out how you actually are oppressed and
what might be done about it.
And then let's figure out a strategy and then let's help you practice the
strategy until you get good at it.
And,
and let's also map out the consequences of not fixing it because people think,
well,
how can I stand up to my boss?
It's like,
that's terrible.
I might risk my job.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
No wonder you're afraid of that.
Maybe you should just shut up.
Let's see what your life would be like in 10 years if you just shut up.
It's like,
you know how bad it is now?
It's like it's going to be way worse than that because you're going to shrink
and shrink and shrink and your boss is going to become more and more tyrannical
and you're going to hate every minute of your life and it's like you want that
or do you want to confront your boss or change jobs?
It's like,
oh,
I see.
It's
like hell here.
It's hell here.
I get it.
I get to pick which of those I'm going to walk down and that's a relief to
people most of the time.
It's so funny because people often think they have their,
they're paralyzed because they think that there's a good option.
Right,
right,
right.
But what are the things you do as a psychotherapist to say,
oh,
no,
you're screwed.
No matter which way you turn.
It's like a crocodile here and it's a wolf there.
And behind you there's a Hyena.
It's like there's no lambs.
You're not in Lam territory.
It's all predators.
Well,
pick your battles,
pick your battle,
and then all of a sudden you're in the battle and then it doesn't matter that
it's a Hyena because your warrior so fine,
bring it on.
This is a common to another point that I picked up from the book that I,
I have a leadership and management consulting company started work with
companies all the time.
And one of the topics has come up a bunch in the past couple of years is,
you know,
when you're,
when you're dealing with someone,
you're dealing with an employee and you got firearm and how this big hard
conversation and et Cetera,
et cetera.
No one wants to have those.
And I always say,
look,
if you have the hard conversation earlier,
it's not so hard because all I have to tell you is,
Hey Jordan,
you know you were late today and we're not supposed to be late.
And you all sorry.
And the problems sorts itself out or it or it doesn't.
And then I got to escalate.
But what you talk about in the book is if there's a problem,
go attack it.
You can go get that problem solved.
Don't go after that dragon.
You know the dragons in there,
go get it.
Well,
your observation is dead on.
It's like,
and this is the problem with being too nice.
Like I don't want regard nice as a virtue or if it's a virtue,
it's a very low order virtue.
Because what nice usually means,
but nice usually means is I don't want to cause conflict now,
even though the consequences of the conflict might multiply into the future.
So let's say you have an employee that's chronically late,
right?
And,
but you,
I don't want to,
I don't really want to disturb them.
I don't want to cause any trouble.
It's like while you're angry about it because they're late and they're not
supposed to be.
So you're getting all bitter and resentful,
plus you're not doing them any favors,
you know,
cause you're also telling them that you can be taken advantage of and that their
lack of discipline is okay.
And then you know,
so then you're going to dislike the employee and you're going to amplify their
other errors in your,
because of your distaste.
And then if they are someone who's taking advantage of you,
then they're going to take advantage of you a little more and then a little more
and then a little more and a little more.
And then you're going to have to have a really difficult conversation or put up
with it.
And that might sink your business,
especially if you're a small business owner.
So by not confronting the dragon when it's like two inches high and can only,
you know,
it's,
it's like it can belch out something like a bic lighter.
You wait until the thing can inflame the whole room and then you say,
oh my God,
like isn't this hellish?
It's like,
well,
you knew that there was something to say.
You knew it,
you knew it a thousand times,
and now you can't just say the one thing,
you have to say the thousand things,
or maybe you have
to say the 10,000 things and it's just destructive in every way.
So yeah,
that's not good.
No.
Here's where I need help with this.
So what I think people might get the ideas,
okay,
if I'm in a relationship with my wife and she gives,
serves me dry chicken again.
Yeah.
Right.
Which is,
which is a common theme in my household.
And actually,
thanks to the Internet,
it's actually changed now because she's gotten thousands of people that have now
sent her how to keep the chicken moist.
So she does a great job.
But for,
for,
um,
you know,
we're talking about two decades of my life.
We're talking about dry chicken.
This is a problem.
And you know what I did?
I didn't say anything because I would drink more water,
more water at dinner.
Yeah.
I fear that sometimes people say,
well,
you know what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna run around and I'm going to tell
the truth to everyone all the time on these little things that don't matter.
Now,
my,
my actual best example that I've ever heard of this,
we had a guy in the podcast named Charlie Plumb.
He was a pilot in Vietnam.
He was shot down in,
um,
in on his last mission of his deployment.
He was shot down.
He was captured.
He was in the Hanoi Hilton for six years.
This is the deal that they had amongst their roommates.
So they had roommates in a room smaller than we're in right now,
and there'd be four of them in there,
three of them in there too.
From there,
depending on what was going on,
if you did something that annoyed me,
if Jordan does something that annoys me,
we got to live together.
If you do something that annoys me,
it's my fault.
It's my fault for allowing.
You Click,
click,
click your nails together.
You pick your nose a lot or you itch your head,
whatever it is that you do,
that bothers me.
It's my problem and I have to absorb it because otherwise what we have is we
have like rats in a cage that are going to know each other apart.
And I thought about that while I was reading the part of the book that was
saying,
and you actually also later in the book talk about,
Hey,
you know,
are you going to get fired over this little stupid thing?
Are you going to absorb?
And I talk about that a lot as a leader,
as a,
as a person in a relationship.
Hey,
there's problems from your boss.
You absorb them and you don't pass them down to your people.
You know,
you,
you want us to do to stay,
work and or stay late and do a bunch of crazy stuff that we don't think we
should be doing.
Cool.
My guys are gonna go home.
I'm going to absorb that.
I'll get it done myself.
I'm not going to,
I'm going to absorb these problems.
Now are there some tertiary effects?
Of course.
Are Secondary effects that now my boss thinks he can get away with that and all
those things.
But I just think there's,
we have to be careful that we're not just throwing spears of truth in people's
heads on a regular basis.
Those are black truths.
The opposite of white lies,
right?
So black truths are truths that you use to hurt other people with
technically in the moment,
the statement is factual,
but the context belies right.
Whereas a white lie,
it's like,
well,
it's a little lie,
but you're trying to support a larger truth.
Not that white white lies aren't optimal.
You know,
it's better not to lie,
but sometimes the
best you can manage as a white lie and then maybe that's pretty good.
Well,
okay,
so then in those sorts of situations you think,
well,
first of all,
I have some rules of thumb.
If someone does something at work that annoys you,
it's like,
write it off,
man.
It's like,
that's once.
what does that mean?
You're having a bad day,
you're having a bad day,
or I'm having a bad dates.
Like it doesn't mean anything.
Do it twice.
I think so.
Okay,
let's write that off.
Write that off.
It's,
that's it's the same issue.
It could still just be circumstance and situation three times.
Okay.
Now there might be grounds for a conversation.
You go and say,
well,
you know,
you put your feet up on my desk like a day ago,
and that was okay.
But then he did it again and then like you did it again and I'm thinking it
actually happened three times.
Right.
So there's no denying it and perhaps that's not optimal.
And then you go for the smallest possible victory.
That's the next thing is like,
I'm not telling you that your,
what would you say that you lack respect or that there's something wrong with
you?
What I'm asking is that if you come in my office,
it would be better for both of us if your feet stayed on the floor.
Is that okay?
You know,
and,
and that's a small thing.
You're not going after the person's character,
right?
You go on after the tiny victory.
So you say to your wife,
look like,
I'm thrilled to death that you're cooking me dinner.
I really,
I'm serious because,
and it could be a hell of a lot worse than it is,
you know?
And,
and maybe I could be more helpful around the kitchen.
That's certainly a possibility.
But I have got this thing with regards to chicken and maybe it's me,
you know,
but could we try for like a month to cook it differently and then we'll revisit
it.
And if I happen to be wrong,
like I'll shut the hell up and she might think,
okay,
well he is kind of useless around the kitchen and he sort of bitchy about the
chicken and all of that.
But maybe I trust him enough to admit that I made a small mistake and rectify it
and we could go long and not have the damn chicken thing hanging over our heads
until we're 80.
Yeah,
right.
You know,
you just,
in your second example there,
you,
I tell people this all the time,
so you're coming into my office and you're putting your feet on the desk.
What I'll generally do is make it my fault.
I have generally say,
Hey Jordan,
I hate to be like a nitpicker.
Yeah.
But I'm really freaked out about germs.
It's really stupid,
but I am.
And when you come in and put your feet on my desk,
it freaks me out.
Can you just do me a favor and not put your foot on your d at the same thing
with,
you know,
with the chicken it's like,
Hey,
you know what?
I have a super sensitive palate.
Refined and I,
yeah,
to super refined sense of about five.
Sorry.
And I just,
yeah,
could we maybe figure out another way to cook that or,
oh,
can we try,
you know,
but I'll take the blame for,
for the situation rather than you're,
you're disrespectful and don't put your feet on my desk.
This is what you don't want to a
more of a position of moral superiority than is absolutely necessary.
One of the things I recommend,
I don't remember if I wrote it in 12 rules for life,
I think I did about how to,
let's say you're in an intractable argument with your wife about who's the most
reprehensible person,
right?
Which is where arguments sort of and when they go to hale,
thanks.
Now you're in one of those arguments and you risk bringing up the past,
which is a very,
very bad idea,
right?
Maybe you're saying something like you've always been this way,
you're this way down,
you'll never change and none of it's good.
It's like,
Oh man,
that's a fight because we're,
where are we going to go from there?
So one of the things I recommend,
and this actually works is when you're in one of these battles and you can't
bloody well get out of it,
you separate each go to your room and you sit and think,
okay,
that person is really wrong.
And I'd like to give them a good stomping and,
but then you think,
no,
I got to live with them.
So that's probably not a good idea,
right?
Cause I don't want to live with someone who's like stomped and angry about it
because they're going to take their revenge.
Like if they have any spirit at all.
So you cannot win an argument with your wife.
That's just wrong.
You can't,
you can make peace,
you can come up with a solution.
But if you,
when she loses and then she's the loser and like unless you want to have a loser
round,
that's not a very good strategy anyway.
So you go to your room and you think,
okay,
fundamentally flawed as my wife is,
particularly in this particular circumstance,
there's probably something stupid idea in the relatively recent past that
increased the probability that we're in this little hellish place.
And you think,
ah,
what was it?
And you think,
Oh God,
I really don't want to know.
It's like,
really don't want to know this.
And so you think,
no,
I'm going to figure out where I'm 1% at fault.
She's 99% wrong,
but I'm,
I'm 1% at fault.
So you sit there and you think,
okay,
what was it?
Then you let your imagination sort of wander over your past stupidities and you
think,
oh,
there was something I did that was like kind of underhanded and devious and
crooked and pathetic and weasely and,
and then you go and you tell her and she does the same thing,
you know,
and she's just as irritated about it as you are.
And then you think,
okay,
and you say,
look,
I'm sorry about that and I know this increased the probability that we're in
this like bitchy pourable place and she does the same thing.
And then you think,
oh yeah,
well we're both pathetic losers and we can quit plan like dominance hierarchy
and then maybe you can have a conversation about how to make it better and that
conversation should be bounded to,
it's like the chicken thing is a really good,
my,
my father in law who I really like,
he used to come,
my wife told me this story.
He used to come home for lunch and his wife would feed them lunch and she always
used little plates and it was like they'd been married for 30 years and one day
he had this explosion at the table about the fact that he did,
he'd had to eat off these damn little plates for 30 years and you know,
it was much more of a large explosion then it had to be.
But it's these little things actually matter.
Hey,
they actually matter that you have to straighten them out.
Cause your life,
especially with your wife,
is composed of about 50 little things that you do every day.
And because you do them every day,
they're not little.
You can just do the arithmetic.
You know?
It's like maybe you don't like the way your wife greets you when you come home.
It's like,
okay,
is that relevant?
Is that important?
Well let's say it takes 10 minutes cause you're thinking about it and you're
coming home and then there's the little aftermath.
It was 10 minutes.
So it's like an hour a week.
It's four hours a month,
it's 50 hours a year.
That's one work week.
It's 2% of your life.
It's like 2% of your life.
Right?
So that's the math.
It's like if you got 50 of those things right,
your whole life would be right.
Think is it worth fighting about?
It's like,
yeah,
it's worth it because it's 2% of your life or what's 1% even whatever.
And then you think,
okay,
well how should people greet themselves when they first come home?
It's like,
well maybe it's not quite like your dog greets you cause your dog is like
reprehensive really happy to see that's just too much.
Right.
Little candle do that.
But maybe you want the person to not be watching TV for the second you entered
the house.
Maybe they should just stop watching TV and come and say,
you know,
hello,
how was your day?
And give you a hug.
That would be a good thing.
And then maybe you do the same thing to them and you practice that for like two
months cause you're both stupid and it's really hard for you to learn anything.
And then you've got that down and that the dinner times are like that too.
Like lots and lots of households mealtimes are really fractured,
which is a bad thing.
Or they're bitter.
It's like I'm,
here's your God damn food.
It's like,
yeah,
I'll eat it,
but I can't stand it and you can't cook.
It's like,
okay,
that's four and a half hours a day,
right for your whole life.
You think you're going to like someone like that?
Not a bit,
man.
You're not going to like them.
So you fix that.
You actually do,
did tell that whole thing in the book.
So that's good.
It's in the right.
And actually the phrasing that you used when you say if you win an argument,
you said something along the lines of you win,
you win that argument,
they're the loser.
Yup.
Now you win that argument a hundred times.
Now in a marriage you win 10,000 times and you are now married to a loser.
And that loser,
that loser is not going to be someone who makes any effort whatsoever,
ever to be attractive to you or anyone else.
Then you'll think,
oh look,
look,
look who I ended up with.
It's like,
no,
look at how you produced.
It's like good work there sky.
And that's the,
that's the so,
so what you're talking about with this argument thing and you look over,
you separate,
you go in your room and you say,
okay,
what did I do wrong?
Did I do wrong?
And that's annoying.
What did I do wrong?
And,
and interestingly,
myself and my,
my,
my buddy Leif Babin and we wrote a book called extreme ownership.
And the whole premise is you take responsibility for when things go wrong and
you say,
yeah,
this was my fault.
So I'll go to clients and I'll be meeting with them.
And I'll say,
you look when you,
if something goes wrong with your team here with you guys made a mistake,
you fail whenever you're trying to,
you know,
you've got to take ownership of it.
You stand up and you say,
hey look,
this was my fault and this is what we're gonna do.
And the people will say,
well,
you know what,
if I did that,
my team is so bad that if I did that with my team,
you know what they'd say?
They'd say,
you're right,
it is your fault.
And he looked at me like,
so you're planning Jocko sucks.
Because if I say,
this is my fault,
my team is going to look at me and say,
you're right,
it is your fault.
And then what do I do?
And like I kind of get a little bit,
maybe a little bit frustrated because I look at them and I say,
that's the whole point.
It actually is your fault.
You're not just saying it to get out of the,
the the problem.
You're not just saying it to make excuses for everything that's happening.
No.
When you say,
Hey,
this is my fault that we got in this argument and then you're ending,
your wife says,
yeah it is.
You don't say no,
no,
no.
You say,
I know and you have to meet her.
It is.
You say,
I know and this is what I'm going to do to fix it.
And if you're a leader and you say it's my fault,
and your team says,
yeah,
you're right,
it is your fault.
You say,
I know.
That's what I just said and here's what we'll do to fix it.
So when you take ownership of a problem,
it doesn't necessarily make the problem go away.
In fact,
it doesn't do that at all.
Once you admit what the problem is and you take ownership for the problem,
then you have to say,
here's what I'm going to do to fix it.
Here's my [inaudible].
Let's say you're a high school kid and he got a tyrant as a teacher,
it's like,
well,
you could,
it could be the case that you have a tire and Teza teacher and the tire it is
particularly on your case and you think,
well,
yeah,
that's an awful thing and this person really is a tire,
and it's like,
yeah,
but you're not very good at dealing with tyrants.
And you might think,
well,
I shouldn't have to be.
It's like fair enough,
man,
because who wants tyrants?
But truth of the matter is is that there is always tyranny and if you don't know
how to deal with it,
if you don't know how to thrive in the face of tyranny,
even then there is something wrong with you.
Now,
doesn't mean that there isn't something wrong with the tyrant.
It's like that's self evident.
But it does mean that you aren't who you could be.
Because if you were everything you could be,
you could manage that situation.
And it might be,
you'd figure out an exit strategy.
I mean,
who the hell knows what the solution would be?
But if you,
if you are conceiving yourself as helpless victim,
then that's what you are.
And I'm not saying that there aren't situations that people find themselves in
where there's very,
well,
it's hard to say,
you know,
that there's very little you can do.
I mean,
that woman that we talked about earlier,
she was in a pretty damn hopeless situation and she found something she could
do.
You know,
and I've read these books,
Viktor Frankl's man's search for meaning and social knits and school leg
archipelago.
I mean he saw people in s pretty damned dire straights and like really mean
really beyond comprehension.
And he noticed even in those situations that people still had their choices to
make.
You know,
and I mean you,
you,
you tread on that ground with extreme hesitancy because you don't say,
well man,
if I was thrown in the Gulag I would've been noble.
It's like,
no,
probably not,
man.
You would have a trustee and about 15 minutes,
you know,
that's the most likely outcome.
So you have to be careful about not getting too high on your horse about such
things.
But it isn't obvious when you're out of choices.
Most of the time you have more choices.
You haven't used all the choices you have.
Most of the time.
Now I've seen people in situations I couldn't help them get out of.
So,
and people die,
right?
I mean,
you have a fatal illness,
you have pancreatic cancer,
like you're dead in six months.
Your choices are limited.
But maybe under those circumstances you figure out how to put your house in
order and be what you can to the people who will be left.
It's something like that.
Okay.
For me and I get a lot of,
and I know you get infinitely more than me,
but I'll get someone that reports to me a problem or a situation that they're in
that seems really bad and,
and what I've found is the solution that they're looking for,
the only solution that they can conceive of is one that is going to provide that
solution within a two week timeframe.
Like that's what we're talking about.
If I'm not,
if this problem isn't solved in two weeks,
then you know this is hell.
And,
and I always kind of report back and say,
Hey,
you're hearing a job right now that I understand it's bad.
I understand it's your boss's terrible vote team is terrible the but whatever
the case is,
would it?
Or you're in a situation where your family is this or whatever.
So conceive a plan right now and it's not going to take two weeks.
It might take six months,
it might take a year.
It might take a year and a half of you saving your money and sending your resume
and getting the other skills that you need if you can.
If you can extend your time and I'll tell you what,
when you,
when you come up with that plan,
when you conceive of that plan,
immediately you have hope.
And when you have hope,
you can continue on through the miserable existence that you're in.
Cause you know they're going to,
you've got a plan and you're gonna get your way out of it.
Absolutely.
Well,
I,
I had a client recently because I've done a lot of consulting as well as
clinical work.
And often my clients come to me,
they're high functioning people.
They have decent jobs,
but you know,
we make a plan.
It's like,
well,
I'm making $75,000 a year right now.
The person says,
I said,
well,
how much?
Well,
okay,
we're gonna,
we're gonna improve that.
Like,
why don't we see if we can triple that,
see if we can triple it.
It's like,
what the hell?
You know,
maybe we can't,
but maybe we can.
Some people do make triple.
That could be you.
Okay.
So what's wrong with you?
Well,
you know,
you're not educated enough.
All right,
so we need to fix that.
Your resume isn't in order,
you're not sending the damn thing out.
It's like,
well then you got to do baseline statistics.
well,
how many times do you have to send out your resume to to move ahead when you're
already in a pretty decent job?
Well,
the answer isn't 10.
The answer is like you have to send out five a day everyday for the next two
years and the,
the rejection rate will be so close to 100% that that's what it will feel like.
Right?
But it's a lottery ticket.
You only have to win once.
So it doesn't matter if you,
if you lose 300 times,
it doesn't matter.
You just need one hit.
So now you got to prepare yourself because it's going to be brutal because
you're sending out all these,
you know,
resumes to jobs.
You're not quite qualified enough for cause you're looking to move up,
brace yourself,
right?
It's going to be nothing but failure.
Nothing but failure.
Well,
in this particular client,
I think it took her two years,
maybe more,
two and a half years of sending out resumes and accelerating her education.
And,
and practicing,
cause she'd get an interview now and then and get very close to it to get that
first move right.
But then she got two more in the next year and she was at Tripler salary.
But you know,
it's like longterm strategic thinking followed by an implementable plan and then
the willingness to tolerate an insane run of ridiculous failures before you
move.
But I've seen that happen to people.
There's no reason that you can't move.
You just have to figure out where you want to move.
You have to figure out what the criteria are for putting you in that position.
And then you have to be some measure of insanely persistent because it's so
unlikely,
right?
The default answer to the question,
can I have this good job?
Is are you out of your mind?
Of course not.
Right,
right.
Well,
it is.
It's like,
and even if you're qualified,
it's like,
yeah,
you and 10 other people.
So there's even an element of chance added,
especially at the end.
You know,
like if you're in the top five,
you've done everything you can can do to control that outcome.
There's some element of chance that's going to be the determining variable
because,
you know,
maybe,
I dunno,
maybe they didn't like the way your suit looked on you and that's the only thing
that's differentiating you from the other candidate.
It's like you also don't want to take that too personally.
It's like,
well,
you hit the top five,
you were shortlisted,
you're in there,
man,
you're in the game.
Do that 10 times,
you'll win one of those contests,
but you got to do it 10 times.
So,
and you know,
even in lower end jobs,
like I,
I've,
I,
I've worked in lots of lower end jobs.
We talked about Dishwasher,
dishwasher,
I share a strong kid.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
I was dishwasher for a while,
but then that was a short order cook and you know,
but more than that,
more importantly than that,
even while I was a dishwasher Washer,
once I kind of got the hang of it,
which was a lot harder than you might think.
Um,
once I got the hang of it,
I was valued member of that team.
It's like,
well,
you're a dishwasher.
It's like,
yeah,
that's one way of looking at it.
Another way of looking at it is that I'm valued member of this team.
And that was actually fun.
Like I was just a kid,
you know,
I was 14 and I was,
I did my job properly and I got treated like an adult.
It was like,
I loved that.
That was great.
And so the fact that I was,
what,
are you a dishwasher or are you a 14 year old adult?
Hey,
I'm a 14 year old adult.
I win,
I win that dishwasher,
no dishwasher.
It's like that's a good game.
And I really did like that.
I mean,
when I look back in my mid adolescence,
it's certainly the case that the,
the Times that we're the best for me,
which when I was working in restaurants because I was,
I was part of the team man.
So you,
one of the sections in the book,
you talk about,
um,
I believe the person's name was lunchbox Lunchbucket
Toro lunch.
But since we're talking about work environments and there's that certain level
of comradery and you actually talk about the seal teams in here where you just
have this,
it's like a non,
I've talked about this before in the seal teams,
it's nonstop,
hyper verbal abuse,
aggression around the clock,
24 hours a day.
You're in a seal platoon.
Like that's the,
that's life.
Any,
any mistake that you make,
any,
any display of weakness is going to be passive.
Oh,
it's going to be ripped apart.
And then if you get all irritated about that,
it's even worse.
Just the dad,
the nicknames,
you talked about lunch bucket,
your nickname was howdy,
howdy doody,
and then be shortened to howdy.
Which was,
which was you felt pretty good about is better.
Yeah,
because you went from how to ut,
which is kind of how he was just kind of cool,
right?
As Western guy and whatever.
But,
but the nicknames that that,
that are in the seal teams,
like I can't with good conscience repeat them because they're just,
they're just horrible,
horrible names.
But there's a comradery around that.
And there's also the way,
as I was reading what you had written about,
these guys were working on a railroad railroad crew.
Yeah.
There's a test.
It's a test.
It's a test to see where you're at so that you're made of can we take,
can you read,
can you tolerate a little bit of irritation?
If the answer to that is no,
it's like,
well maybe we don't want you around them cause some of your rotating things are
likely to come down the pipe.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's not just
to me.
To me it proves if you've got someone that can take it.
Right.
It's not just that they can take some random joking insults like they can,
they can take it.
They can take it.
Yeah.
That's what you're testing for.
It's like,
can you take it?
Lunchbucket couldn't write because people would laugh at his lunch bucket and
he'd get all upset.
It's like,
well you have a stupid lunch pocket.
you know your mum packed it.
How about you laugh at yourself?
Yeah.
My mom packed this.
I know.
It's kind of stupid.
That would have been the end of it.
He would just have to say that it's like,
but I didn't want to hurt her feelings.
It's like,
oh okay.
You know,
fine,
you got your stupid lunch bucket.
But no,
he couldn't handle that,
you know.
So yeah,
it was,
it was horrible.
It comical to watch at the same time because of the level of,
and people have written me about that and they said,
oh you know,
poor Lunchbucket.
It's like,
cause they're all compassionate I think.
No,
no,
not poor Lunchbucket.
It's like clue the hail in buddy you had your chance.
You know,
that was a desirable job,
that real crew job in the summer because it was high paying,
you know,
and they weren't easy to come by those jobs.
And so the fact that he got hired onto that crew is a real opportunity for him.
You could make a pile of money into summer out working on the rail crew and
all you had to do was take some ribbing with good grace,
not suck up to the management too badly and not have other people do your job.
That was all,
that was all you had to do,
but he couldn't do that.
And so he got run off and it was like,
grow the hell up buddy.
You know these guys win a hundred people are teasing you then probably they're
not wrong.
You are getting teased like that as well.
Well,
when you,
when you stop reacting,
it's no longer fun.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well it also gives you an opportunity to tease back.
It's like this,
you can show your wit.
And one of the things that working class guys in particular,
which is one of the things I really loved about working class jobs is there,
they're always looking for some humor.
So it's like if,
if person a is teasing person B,
that's kind of comical.
But if person B comes back with a good comeback,
it's like,
that's even better.
You know?
So I think that's a lot of how those jobs are rented.
Tolerable,
right?
It's their hard dirty jobs.
Dishwasher's a good example of that.
It's not dangerous,
although cooking,
she's,
you know,
got to watch your step.
I got burned a lot when I was cooking.
But what makes those jobs not only tolerable but even desirable,
is that you can develop a tremendous amount of camaraderie around them.
I've never really experienced that at a professional level job that just doesn't
happen the same way.
And it's really,
there's a real loss and not so it's,
it's,
it's fun to be part of a team that's doing,
you know,
grubby hands on things and,
and having a ridiculously entertaining,
vicious,
cruel and evil time while you're doing it.
That's very entertaining.
The,
this new kids book I wrote,
So,
uh,
the kid mark,
he's getting made fun of by this.
He's a different kind of bullies,
like a mental bullying that,
that verbally abuses people and he gets called plate face by this character and
to eventually it gets in trouble for throwing us something at the kid because
he's calling him plate face plate.
But eventually the way he befriends the kid is by heat.
They have to do a self portrait class and he draws a picture of himself looking
like a plate and he shows it again,
the kid laughs.
And all of a sudden their buddies.
And it's like that's what you do.
You take away that you take away the joy of,
of being so he did and irritated by people that are making fun of you and you
just kill it.
Right?
She jujitsu in some sense.
Well,
I had an experience with that about three years ago.
I'd put my videos up online and people kept saying that I sounded like Kermit.
And I thought,
well one person said it and I thought,
well,
whatever.
But then like five people said it and I thought,
oh my God,
like this Kermit thing.
So then I went and listened to Kermit and I thought,
oh no.
It's like,
really?
I really sound like Kermit,
you know?
And so then,
well then I started to play with it a little bit.
You know,
I used the puppet when I went away,
when I went to speak to university students and I made frog jokes and then I
made a video.
I mean a couple of videos that sort of featured me as a frog.
And I mean,
it's crazy,
right?
It's ridiculous.
But,
but that's,
but,
but the teasing never got mean because of that,
you know?
And the same thing's happened online to a larger degree is people keep making
memes of me like,
and there's,
I don't know,
there's lots of them.
There's way too many to even keep track of.
And I was watching that happen and I thought,
okay,
this is a good thing because there's humor and wherever there's humor,
that's a good thing and they're making fun of me.
But it's gentle,
you know?
Most of it was pokey,
you know,
like,
well you sounded like this damn puppet.
What do you think about?
It's like,
well,
if I had to pick someone to sound like probably wouldn't be a puppet,
but that'd be a puppet.
Kermit is not a bad one.
Could be a lot worse.
Like it could be Miss Peggy,
I couldn't be in that.
It also,
thank God that didn't happen.
But the memes have never got vicious because,
you know,
I'll post them if they're funny and satirical and then they won't get vicious
because they don't have to.
It's like,
can we poke fun at you?
yeah,
please do and the more the better really because that'll also help keep my feet
on the ground and keep me awake and plus it's funny and like one of the things
about life is that a sense of humor,
that's a good thing to to arm yourself with because sometimes you just don't
have anything other than that.
Like my daughter,
when she recounts her,
the horrors of her adolescence,
she,
she had to have her hip and her ankle replaced because they both deteriorated
and beyond repair beyond the possibility of repair and she was like an agony for
literally for years.
It was just awful.
She can tell that story in a way that will just make you die of laughter and
it's like,
well thank God for that because what else do you have in a situation like that?
Man,
if you,
if,
and sometimes it's so dark that your sense of humor is just about gone and then
you're in real trouble,
but lots of times that's what you've got against the slings and Arrows of
outrageous fortune.
It's like you see this with people,
especially people who have been through really hard times and they were witty
things.
There'll be bleak,
bleak,
and they'll crack a joke and you think,
well thank God man,
you could pop up above that and see above it a bit and,
and like,
you know,
tap it with a bit of irony and thank God for that.
So when the comedian start to get silenced,
there's real trouble.
And that's been happening to some degree in Canada.
And you know,
comedians are increasingly not willing to go speak on university campuses say,
and that's when the comedians can't talk.
That's a really bad site because that's the,
that comedies,
that's the triumph of the human spirit over adversity,
right?
That's why guys in these horrible jobs are often so unbelievably funny.
It's like,
well what else do they have?
You know,
and actually that's a lot to be funny like that too.
That can,
that can move you through a lot of dismal.
So you know,
I'm paying attention to the time cause I know in case someone can't tell if that
were by an airport right now.
But to kind of bring this a little bit too close,
first of all,
we didn't cover anything that I wanted to cover today,
so we should all know that I have to do that with my talks.
Like oh that's not the talk I plan.
Well yeah,
your first biblical talk,
you covered the first line of Genesis,
right?
I made it one line deep in two and a half hours.
Well done.
Well thought.
But one of the things in it,
and I think it's a good note to end on at least a little bit to touch on it
because you're kind of talking about it right now is you know the last rule is
to to pet a cat when you encounter one on the street.
Yeah.
It's basically find a little bit of joy in these common things when it's a
chapter about about my daughter's experience and like it was brutal man.
It was brutal.
She was literally walking around on two broken legs for two years and she had to
take incredibly high doses of opiates and so had all the problems that went
along with that.
She had to take Ritalin to stay awake.
It's like,
and she was in all likelihood she was dying.
There's a bunch of reasons for that and those were just some of her health
problems.
Those,
those weren't even the worst ones strangely enough.
So it was bloody brutal man.
And one of the things we told her,
and we manage this thank God,
is I told her once the disease started to develop,
she had rheumatoid arthritis very,
very seriously.
I said to her when she was a little kid,
he said,
look kid,
this is going to be rough man.
This is going to be rough and,
and here's what you could do to make it worse.
It's like use your illness as an excuse.
You do that at your peril.
You do that a hundred times.
You will not be able to tell the difference between suffering that stops you
from moving forward and an excuse for not living.
And you'll be done.
Said,
never.
Never,
never use your illness as an excuse.
Like if you can't do it,
you can't do it.
You know,
we had a good experience with that.
It's written in the book when we bought her a scooter because she couldn't use
public transportation and we were all freaked out about that because like,
well,
she has damaged bones and you know,
a broken hip and all of this,
like you're going to buy that kit a scooter.
Really?
It's like,
well,
what are you going to do to keep her in her bedroom?
He won't think that's a good idea.
Tell her she can't go out in the world.
It's like have the damn scooter.
So after a while she had to get licensed for it.
There's a licensing procedure and to do that,
she actually had to ride a motorbike and so she trained to ride the motorbike
like not very long after she had her hip replaced,
I think it was six weeks,
something like that too.
Of course,
we're all freaked out about that too because it's like,
oh man,
she has to ride a motorbike and she has this hip.
And it's like,
what are we going to do?
And she went and she did the motorcycle left first one,
but she dropped the bike a couple of times and some kid wiped out and rolled
like 30 feet and that kind of freaked her out,
unsurprisingly.
And,
and so then the second day she went with her mom to do the motorcycle training.
She also got trained to ride a motorcycle.
And,
uh,
the second day she woke up and she said,
I don't think I can do this.
And we thought,
well,
you know,
that's understandable.
It's like,
I can understand that.
And we talked through it and we said,
look,
here's what to do,
man is like,
yeah,
you can't do it.
We understand why you're afraid of it.
You can't hold the bike up that well.
Um,
but
why don't you just go,
like go in the car with your mom and see how you feel when you get there,
because you'll get close and you get right up to it.
Maybe you can say no and you have to sit in the car and like,
that's life and we get it,
but maybe you don't have to.
And she went there so she thought that was okay.
And she went there and she picked up the damn motorbike and got her license and
everybody cheered at the end.
And then she could drive her God damn scooter around.
And thank God for that because you know,
she used to go out there and she put on her helmet and she'd go on her scooter
and she was like ready to go up in the world.
And so that's like,
that's the difference between making your kids safe and making them strong.
And it was touching bloody go.
You know,
cause it could have easily been that she would have been in a little accident
with her motorcycle and broken her leg and then,
and we would have thought,
oh,
what kind of horrible parents are.
We,
she's already got problems and we put her on a damn scooter in the middle of the
city.
It's like,
well,
you're going to be competent,
are you going to be safe?
It's like there's nothing safer than competence.
And so,
and it was great for her because it was just one more act of courage,
you know,
and,
and it,
and she loved that Damn Scooter.
She had it for like six years and it was a really good idea.
Risky as hell,
but really a good idea.
So,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
again,
I'm looking at the clock.
We've got to get you out of here.
Um,
first of all,
12 rules for life.
Um,
an antidote to chaos that's out right now.
It's number one on Amazon in America,
UK,
Canada,
everywhere.
That's pretty awesome.
I'm,
I'm uh,
yeah struck wordless by it.
Yeah.
Everyone should just get it.
Um,
and because we didn't talk about anything I wanted to talk about today,
will you come back?
We'll do this book and everyone likes to read the books if I can,
if they can before I do the podcast on them.
So this will give everyone a chance to read it,
which will be awesome.
Uh,
any other things?
Well,
I should say I've got this online program called self authoring and uh,
I'm offering your viewers a end listeners,
a 20% discount that helps you write out and autobiographies so you can figure
out like what you haven't sorted out about your life.
It helps you write an analysis of your virtues and faults so you can rectify the
faults and capitalize on the virtues and helps you make a plan for the future.
And I would say to your listeners,
don't be afraid to do it badly because a bad plan,
a bad account for yourself and a bad plan is way better than no account for
yourself and no plan.
It's way better.
So do it.
Do it badly.
It'll,
it'll help orient you in your life.
And we have a preponderance of,
of scientific data showing,
for example,
that people who've done the future authoring portion of this,
that's the plan are like 30% more likely to stay in university,
has an overwhelming effect and it works best people who are doing worst,
which is really quite cool.
So there's that.
I have a personality test@understandmyself.com and you can go there and get an
analysis of 10 aspects of your personality.
It's kind of a harsh test.
Like it'll tell you actually what you're like and it'll probably make you angry,
you know,
because maybe not,
but it probably will,
but it'll tell you,
it'll help you figure out what jobs you might be suited for,
but it'll also tell you where you're weak and could be stronger.
And so that's bitter medicine.
But um,
but it's better to know.
It's better to know because then you can do something about it.
So I would say those are two useful things and I'd encourage people to their
inexpensive,
give them a try,
they'll,
they're helpful.
And on top of that,
you've got your podcast.
Yup.
You've got your youtube channel,
which has hundreds of hours worth of lectures and is fantastic.
Jordan peterson.com as well and well,
I just wanted to thank you for coming on the podcast again,
but more important.
I want to thank you for continuing to do what you do.
I know it's hard work and I know it's taxing on you and on your family life and
all that.
Yeah,
it beats suffering.
Stupidly does and I know for a fact that you're having an incredibly positive
impact all over the world.
Getting people everywhere to try to at least grow the hell lie,
grow the hell up,
grow up to speak the truth,
make themselves and make their buy the world a better place.
Wouldn't that be good?
It couldn't be a better place.
That would be good if we could manage that.
Yeah,
indeed.
Thanks for coming on the bed.
Well,
we have excused Dr. Jordan Peterson from the,
is this a recording studio?
No,
we're in a rented office space shift.
Make shift.
Jordan had to go catch a plane and
continue to get out there and make the world a better place.
Good for him.
Good for us.
And Echo.
Speaking of making the world a better place,
maybe you can let us know how we might be able to make our world a little bit
better.
Sure,
of course.
Yeah.
First thing we can do is stay on the path.
Oh.
And part of staying on the path is maintaining our physical capability and
competent copy.
Competency.
Is it competence or competence?
Tints.
See,
competency.
We're going to maintain that.
That's what we're going to do on the path.
So we had chocolate supplements.
Obviously we already know if you don't know Krill oil,
joint warfare.
So Jocko,
Super Krill oil.
That's a Krill oil supplement joint where warfare is the glucosamine.
Can Drayton and curcumin.
Yes.
Very good things for your joints.
Um,
we,
you know,
at some point we'll go through everything that's in there.
Yeah.
Not Today.
We'll do something so that,
cause I don't wanna sit here and talk about,
but it's good.
Yeah,
it's good.
Use it.
Yeah.
I use it the,
and it's not the kind where it's good because it's generally healthy to take
these things,
which it is,
but that's not the,
the main
push in my opinion.
Check.
The main thing is that if your joints are kind of kind of off Jack,
like soar,
do Jujitsu a lot to anything.
Brought a few.
If you do
brick laying,
what does that Mason Mason if you're um,
yeah,
like just from you know,
back elbows and then you'd start taking this,
you'll see that you'll feel that difference specifically.
Yeah.
And as a generally healthy anyway,
maintain the joints,
maintain the competency of your joints with Jocko,
super krill joint warfare.
Take them every day.
That's what I do in the routine.
Also discipline preworkout it's a pre workout for me.
It's,
it's a pre mission for me.
It's a pre mission.
She straight up progression cognitive enhancer.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you the only downfall of it right now,
while there's a couple,
number one,
it tastes delicious.
So you want to drink a lot of it.
Dale the other day,
I drank a lot of it and then I had to go and give a speech.
Yeah.
I had to use the restroom right before I went on stage with John.
I'm like,
yes.
Be careful.
Well,
that's a general thing.
It doesn't have to be juggled.
Discipline.
You can do that with water.
Tearful.
Yeah.
You want to be careful with,
didn't you eat some of it?
Like,
oh,
can we use that?
Ate some of it today.
It's,
see,
I'll be trying to avoid that.
And again,
it just took a mouth.
A little scoop.
Yeah.
And it's not too bad.
In fact,
you know what,
uh,
you know when you get like a shot of some really nasty alcohol and keep her do
it.
Sure.
But it gives you like a little hook.
Yeah,
sure.
That.
Where do you take just the straight powder,
which I'm now doing.
Apparently it's gives you a little bit,
it gives you a little,
not only you get the,
the effects of what's in it,
but you get a little bit of a,
the main line deal.
Yeah.
That's kind of like,
yeah.
When you're a kid,
you buy the little Koolaid,
you know when you,
before you make the Koolaid.
Yeah,
you get like a little,
you try that stuff straight and kind of what it's like only it's not quite as
horrible as that.
Better than that.
It's better than Kuleana.
Oh yeah,
definitely better than Cruz.
Good Jocko made it taste good.
He's into the tastes good stuff.
Anyway.
It's called De Jong Disa.
It's called discipline called.
You'll see it anyway.
get@originmain.com and also@originmean.com you get,
that's where he can get your geek,
so you don't that I want to give him still ask me what Geek get.
No,
don't ask anymore.
no,
no.
As good.
I'll tell you.
He'll tell you and this is what I'll tell you.
Go to origin,
pick from there,
whichever one you want.
Plenty of color and a planning colors but did legit.
You have white.
I have one blue Gucci that had never used.
All I have is white.
I have a black gay.
Someone gave me a black gay and that's cool,
but I've never used it.
But because a lot of people ask me that too.
What color should I get?
Yeah,
what color should you get?
I am very traditional and I used the white gay,
but I do have a deaf guy that's black.
I guess he's on,
but some schools they don't even allow other colors then white and blue.
That's true.
But Pete says black is,
that is the number one seller don't care.
Like if just all colors blend.
Now can you compete Ibj GF with a black guy.
I don't know.
I forget.
But here's what we were talking about.
When you're a little kid and you think about martial arts,
what do you want to be the Ninja?
You want to be a Ninja?
You got a 36 year old guy or a 28 year old guy and he finally,
he's feeling kind of Ninja man is doing the Jujitsu.
You can take that one extra step and he's got a black geek boom Ninja in a,
in a matter of speaking.
Yeah.
And I,
I actually felt that that's part of the reason why I don't get a black key cause
I,
I kind of wanted like,
not like there's a Charles Bronson movie feathers.
What do you mean an old Charles Bronson movie called the mechanic?
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a scene where the traditional karate guy is going to fight a guy that's
got some new tricks up his sleeve and the traditional karate guy has to get nuts
on him,
but he's in the,
just a plain white t,
eh?
Yeah,
that's the tradition.
And Charles Bronson to,
yeah.
So I'm just,
you know,
yeah.
And in the line,
strangely,
I mainly stick to white because it's kind of,
that's the,
the main,
like I'm not doing too much with the,
with the cool black one because let's face it,
the,
the black one,
like you said about being a Ninja and it looks cool but does it looks really
cool and,
but I didn't want to roll in and be like,
and they think,
well look where you feel real cool with your black geek kind of being,
even though the thing is,
I think it's progressed beyond that.
It's totally,
it's beyond that.
Now.
You are not,
you are not standing out at all and you have a wacky now you might be,
if you go to a traditional,
you know,
school that has only white geese.
Yeah,
you're going to stand out.
You come into victory,
MMA and fitness.
You could be wearing a purple.
You,
no one's going to care.
No one's even looking at your second camouflage.
No one cares.
You might be like,
Dang,
that's a cool camouflage game that might say that.
Just put a choke hold on your and get after it.
So there it is.
I would say if they're saying,
Hey Jocko,
echo what?
Gee,
should I get,
what color should I get?
We know origin.
What color should I get a ask your school first.
Because some they don't allow,
you ain't gonna buy your cool black gay or there's like a army green ways.
Their army green one.
Yeah,
you're going to buy it and they looked dope and you're solid.
You're ready to go.
And you come in and they say you can't train with that.
You can't have that.
So ask your school first.
If they allow our colors then owns up to Uga.
Yeah,
but,
but the the point is with asking what color is that?
I think I think that they're like,
hey,
is there like a violation if I get this cool black one and you answered it.
Yeah.
Now No,
no.
Unless your school does,
it's literally no factor.
Literally no factor.
So they've got a lot anyway.
Origin mean.com that's where you get them also on it.com/jocko this is where I
get
the kettle bells,
the dope kettle bells.
You didn't talk about rash,
rash guards.
Oh at origin.
Yeah.
And because the reason that popped into my mind,
because they have spots now cause they have spats now.
The first run us bats are green and like some other color.
Yellow or green.
Yeah.
Right.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I sent Peter text now I'm not a gust.
Fats wearing dude.
I,
I'm not wearing tights.
Not Happening.
She's no sir.
Nothing against people that do.
There some,
there's some crazy,
you did two guys out there that are wearing tights.
Like you read about the amen.
I said as it,
I said,
Hey Pete,
I'm not wearing tights.
Yeah,
I know a lot of people that do make some black ones or something else.
he's got it.
Yeah.
So you can get,
obviously the rash guards are good to go.
Yeah.
But now you can also get
okay
spots that are not,
so we're sticking with spats,
spats when we figured out the root of stats right here were dope.
Yeah.
It's a good thing.
I thought it would route back to you know,
some Ballerina,
some ballerina thing.
No,
it's war.
Yeah.
It's where you were born,
your legs.
When you were off cavalry men.
Yup.
Yeah.
So we can say spats.
It's been approved yet.
The whole the same thing.
Yeah.
It's you,
you tape your shoe and you're so we're good ankle.
Yeah.
Fully interesting color choice.
The first one.
Here's the thing though about this fats.
Yeah.
Some colors you don't see like eat,
like if I was like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm gonna wear this lime green and yellow thing,
whatever shirt,
spats,
whatever.
And you'd be like,
lime green,
yellow.
That just doesn't even sound good.
I'm looking at these two colors.
I don't think that's going to look good.
But then you put it on a shirt or spots or something and then you put it on,
you're like,
oh Dang.
That kind of works for some reason.
I'm not saying lame greening yellow does that.
I'm just saying certain color combinations.
Here's the interesting thing.
Pete's my bro,
right?
Sure.
Yeah.
My need to leave with the first time I had her,
um,
uh,
Skype conversation with Pete [inaudible].
My wife was like,
it sounded like you were talking to yourself.
Yeah.
And when I was a four hour conversation,
by the way.
Now with that,
that being said,
I wouldn't have made spots that look like the first bath he had came out with in
a million years.
Now.
Now here's the funny thing.
I can't even say,
Hey Pete,
don't you know?
No one's gonna like those.
You know why?
Because my sense of fashion,
yeah.
Is so off of fashion is nonexistent.
It's literally non existent if you even had one.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's right.
Well,
no,
it's not existent.
Yeah.
If you had fun,
it would be get it and it's like double nones.
Yeah.
Well,
so that's why I can't even say,
hey Pete,
I can't say I can't make a blanket statement like Pete.
It's people won't like those.
Yeah.
I can't even say that because I have no idea.
So I just said,
what I do know is people would definitely like some black ones,
right?
Yeah.
That's pretty safe to say.
So yeah.
Yeah.
That's that.
I don't mind the Greenland by the way,
but even we've had this stuff,
we've had issues like this where you make things that I just don't,
yeah,
unapproved.
Not,
yeah,
they're on approved or unapproved across the board.
Yeah.
But I just know you just kind of just don't know and I say,
okay.
You know,
I don't know.
That's,
I gotta stay humble over here.
Yeah.
I can't claim to claim to have any,
any flooding to stand on at all when it comes to fashion,
but any kind and haircuts.
I'm pretty good with those.
You know what?
Yeah,
sure.
If your head,
I agree.
Next question.
So yeah,
again,
or do you mean.com there's a lot of cool stuff on these hoodies and stuff too,
by the way,
which,
and this is a,
this is a buy it and not biased.
What do you call it?
Subjective.
When I was wearing the full origin sweat suit,
I don't,
I laid down on the couch,
just took a break or whatever.
No,
I don't normally do that till the break from what?
Cruising,
you know,
doing whatever it is I was doing.
Took a break,
lay down on the couch,
full sweat suit on origin.
It was the most comfortable moment I had in recent memory and just so everyone
knows,
if you're talking about echoes comfort levels that are already existing bi,
it saved our lives.
I know that,
you know comfort.
I know about it and very familiar with it and yeah,
it was not saying a lot,
so yeah,
there it is.
Okay.
Backed on it.
The kettle bells that I get,
the whole set all muscles that
primal bills,
Zombie bills,
legend bills,
they're the kettlebells.
That's where you get them on a.com/jocko also.
They got some cool Macy's on there.
Jeff was the Mace,
right?
I do,
yeah.
Pounder.
You think 20 pounds is not heavy.
It's heavy.
Yeah.
That's one of those things and we kind of talked about it before where you wait
like wait like this many pounds or kilos,
whatever prior to,
it's not all created equal,
like if it's shaped in a certain form or formulas or whatever.
Right.
It's way different.
Like my daughter,
I forget how I forget.
How much do you do in ways now,
like 53 pounds or something like that to be pounds.
Nothing as far as lifting for she lifted.
Yeah.
Trey lift hurt when she don't want to be lifted.
Right.
She was like,
she is a good piece to like hundred 50 pounds.
Nonetheless.
The point there is with these Mesas and there's all this cool stuff on there.
If you want to vary up your workout,
make an interesting unlike was workup,
make it make yours interesting.
If you want to do that,
you don't have to.
There's some really good stuff on there.
Check them out and you know,
if you want something,
get something.
Also when you get Jordan Peterson's 12 rules
just called 12 rule,
12 rules,
travelers for life,
an antidote to chaos.
Jordan B.
Peterson.
It's 12 rules for life is like,
it seems like a big claim,
you know?
Yeah.
But they're pretty,
they're pretty solid.
Pretty solid.
Yeah.
Follow the salt nonetheless that uh,
that is a good one.
Um,
when you get down and any of the,
any of the other books,
don't worry,
I organized them off or you go to Jocko podcast.
Somebody said the other day on the Internet,
he said to me,
Oh,
you should have a book club.
We got a book club going to Jocko podcast.com and click on books.
All the books are there.
That's the club right there.
Don't have to ask me about the book club.
The books are there.
Alright,
yeah,
idea.
We've got to organize for you by episode.
By the way,
a little brief description.
Click on there.
Boom.
Get your book from there.
It's a good way to support ticks to Amazon.
You can get your book if you are doing other shopping.
Hey,
carry on.
Just do your thing.
No one's going to stop you from that of course,
and that supports the podcast.
Good way to support small action.
Big Reaction.
Also,
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
That one seems obvious.
I know,
but it's a good way to support just a little good way to support view of funny
review.
I'm go like once a week.
Now I go and read all the new reviews for gems.
There's some gems in there.
She has freed up gyms.
Yeah,
if you feel like it.
Um,
yeah.
So,
so subscribe,
rate,
review and subscribe to Youtube.
We have a youtube channel.
If you didn't know that already,
um,
that's where the video version of this podcast resides.
You liked that.
These eyes,
good job.
Also excerpts on there.
If you don't listen or watch,
should I say the whole episode or episodes,
got some excerpts on that.
You can just watch a little,
you know,
little excerpts,
little tidbits of the podcast,
a little ideas,
little lessons,
tips of advice,
shorter form.
You know,
when you take a break at work or whatever,
check.
Not that you should be watching youtube at work,
but if you are,
you watch this,
boom,
get back to work more effective.
Probably.
Probably also some other stuff on there.
I'm going to,
we're going to try to slowly add more and more,
which is to say content,
not just for the sake of adding content by the way,
because I make videos from time to time,
very spaced out.
You know,
I'm trying to get them done.
Then the lessons we're going to put more,
there's going to be more and more on their to new year.
Right.
Well it's February now cause cheap bro.
Anyway,
moving on.
Also Jack was a store,
it's called Jocko store.
Jocko store.com
that this is the website online store where you can get discipline equals
freedom shirts,
rash guards,
the victory MMA and fitness shirt that Jocko always wears.
Like Einstein by the way.
I think and Stan were the same thing everyday too.
Is that why you do it?
No,
I do it cause it's simple.
Not Because Einstein does it actually they say that this is you and Einstein
where the same thing every day for the same reason is what they say less
decisionmaking.
Yeah,
cause your decision making,
you know,
resources.
I don't really believe all that.
I just believe,
I don't feel like sitting around thinking about what I'm gonna wear in the
morning just so I have a shirt drawer.
Guess what I said?
Sure.
It's pulling out.
Put It on,
right.
You have bigger things to make decisions about and think about.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
And that's what I read too.
So you guys,
you and Einstein are like,
I don't want to say obsessed.
You're like,
you're just real into
more important things.
So what you wear,
that's that.
That's,
that shouldn't take up too many of your decision making resources.
The thing about Jocko store,
yeah.
I don't know if you've ever made this clear.
Well,
maybe you have,
but if you want to support the podcast,
that's a good way to support the podcast for a while.
People want us to do a thing where you donate money.
Yeah.
And I said,
well no,
people want to support that.
We're not going to ask for money and give them nothing.
Yeah.
We'll give them something,
a tee shirt.
A hat.
A sticker.
Yeah.
Good stuff.
By the way,
it's about the shirt that makes the man,
it's the man that makes this shirt.
So okay.
There you go.
Nonetheless there are and that cause you're the one that makes these shirts make
it so it's a different thing.
I think I saw it on the movie.
Uh Oh was it the one with Sean Connery and Catherine said Catherine Zeta Jones
and you know I remember they had to steal something.
Continue by email.
What movie I'm talking about.
Anyway,
there's some hoodies on there.
Some hats on there were restocking.
Actually I'm doing a thing because the people email cause you know there stuff
out of stock and guess what?
Not never again.
I'm hesitant to say,
never say never,
but yeah,
never again.
Okay.
So everything is in stock right now.
Not necessarily come back when you're ready.
Okay.
Any time.
Just keeping your lane that I'm working on is all very close to being complete.
Okay.
So there'd be available and some new stuff's going to be on there.
Also rash guards on there for Jujitsu or for anything physical,
you know you're doing physically.
Do you want to keep your range of motion,
you know,
whatever.
Anyway.
You know what?
Rash guards,
they're,
I think they're pretty dope.
I'm also women's stuff on there and I am not saying,
I say this a lot.
Let me say it again.
I'm not saying buy something.
I'm thing going there.
Just look.
If you don't want anything,
didn't,
don't get something,
but if you do on something,
get something.
It's a good way to support also.
That's really a deep,
you know,
I'm trying to keep,
if you want something,
get something.
If you don't want something don't.
Yeah.
All right,
cool.
We'll abide by that.
Is it kind of like,
you know how like when people say it is what it is
there,
you know what to say.
Hey,
it is what it is.
Yes.
[inaudible] not going to be anyone but Jocko.
Jocko was Jockos through,
right.
Same thing.
Then why do you say that?
You know kind of,
I say that for the same reason.
Also psychological warfare.
If you didn't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks.
Jocko tracks,
not Jocko,
plenty Ukulele or the violin or what else do you play?
Violin.
I can't really play the drums too well either.
Yeah,
but you play stuff nonetheless.
It's none of that.
It's Jocko to giving you,
so each track is jock a Jockos.
How should I say?
Tips that really tips.
They're kind of tips on how to eliminate the weakness that you're feeling at any
given moment on your path,
on your campaign,
on the campaign against weakness.
That's what it is.
So if you're about to skip your workout because a,
you don't feel like it be,
you don't think you have time or something like this,
or usually it's because you don't feel like it because you worked out yesterday,
your kind of sore,
like you were going to do squats today,
but you did a bunch of burpees yesterday,
suit lower back,
and your quads,
they're kind of sore.
So you're like,
maybe I'll just do it tomorrow.
No.
So all you gotta do,
but in psychological warfare,
listen to isn't.
There's a track for that and he'll,
he'll just explain just in his own little Jocko way,
explain why you shouldn't do that,
why you should just do the workout and after you listen to it,
you'll be like,
Dang,
that makes sense.
And guess what?
Boom.
All of a sudden you're doing the workout.
You didn't skip it.
It's what you do.
If you like that,
you can also get discipline equals freedom field manual on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
other MP3 platforms.
It's not on audible.
It's not on honorable.
It's available as an album.
Actually two albums.
Also,
you can get Jocko white tea,
which as everybody now knows will increase your dead lift to a minimum of 8,000
pounds.
Been proven
over and over again.
Everyone knows it now.
It's really not impressive anymore since so many people are hitting that 80,000
pound Max books.
Jordan B.
Peterson maps of meeting is his first book.
It's old.
It's big,
it's expensive.
I have it.
It's a great read.
Also 12 rules for life and I had to do to chaos way the warrior kid,
so where the warrior kid kid's book teaching kids to how get how to get on the
path.
Now there's a new book coming out,
a new warrior kid book.
It is available now on Amazon.
It's called a way of the warrior kid Mark's mission.
It's a followup.
The first book was fifth grade,
the second book,
sixth grade.
Mark's getting a little older.
Guess what?
He's still got some problems to solve and he's going to solve them so you can
order that.
Also,
as I already mentioned,
discipline equals freedom field manual that is available.
If you want to get bigger,
stronger,
faster,
smarter,
more disciplined,
better get that book and then implement it because you can get the book and sit,
sit around and play video games.
It's not going to make you any of those things.
You have to actually get it.
You have to read it,
you have to implement it,
so that works.
Oh,
also with the warrior kids,
don't forget,
you can get some more of your kids soap.
Basically.
I got some.
Did you get something?
Yeah.
It's good to go.
Irish oaks ranch.com young Aiden,
who's a warrior kid making his own soap business owner.
Age 12
yeah.
Check that out.
Extreme ownership book by myself and my brother Leif Babin.
It's about combat leadership.
It's about how to lead.
That's what it's about and people think that's a simple thing.
It's not even her German beat.
Jordan B.
Peterson say today,
leadership is very complicated.
He's right,
so extreme ownership will help you in your leadership skills,
tactics,
and strategies.
Also,
if you need leadership guidance and direction at your company,
at Your Business or at your team,
beyond what we give you here on this podcast and beyond the books,
I have a leadership and management consulting company.
It's called echelon front,
where we will get the leadership you have and thereby your whole organization
aligned and moving forward together.
It's me.
It's Leif Babin.
It's JP Denelle.
It's Dave Burke.
You can email info@echelonfront.com or you can go to the website echelon front
dotcom.
Also,
there is the monster.
This is a leadership seminar that hits you like an atom bomb.
So the monster,
everyone that's been to it,
there's nothing else like it.
The people that work at the hotels,
we've done it out and him,
he said there's nothing else like it,
so it's awesome if you want to come to it.
We're only doing two masters this year.
We don't have time to do more.
We're doing one in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th that's for the east coast people May 17th and 18th of
Washington DC,
and we're going to do San Francisco October 17th and 18th that's for your west
coast people.
Those are the only two monsters that we're doing this year.
We're not doing Vancouver.
We're not doing Atlanta.
We're not doing Memphis.
We're not doing Tampa.
Those are all great cities,
but we're not going to do a monster there.
We've had four monsters already.
San Diego,
New York City,
San Diego again,
and Austin,
Texas.
All the mustards that we've done have sold out.
These two that we're doing this year are going to sell out as well.
So if you want to come registered@extremeownership.com we will see you there.
And until then,
if you want to get on the path with us,
you can find us.
We'll be cruising on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Dad's face.
Dot Buki Bull Ha
the Jordan Peterson is at Jordan B.
Peterson.
He's also got the youtube channel,
Jordan Peterson,
he's got Jordan peterson.com echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally,
thanks to all of you,
I know a lot of men and women in uniform.
Listen to this podcast.
I hear from you all the time.
Well,
we would not have this podcast if it wasn't for you overseas holding the line
and keeping evil at bay and to the people in uniform here at home,
police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
and the rest of you.
First responders.
Thank you for keeping us safe inside our borders
and to everyone else out there moving through life and that's good,
that's fine.
But I recommend you don't just move through life.
I recommend you move down the path,
get stronger and faster and smarter and better every day.
Aim to be the best.
And as Jordan Peterson,
right so eloquently in his book,
always place your becoming above your current being.
In other words,
get up and get after it
till next time.
This is echo and Jocko out.